la séance est ouverte bonjour à tous
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement
la première question sera posée par
monsieur Éric Ciotti pour le groupe les
républicains
merci et madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre
la France se bloque depuis quelques
jours des millions de Français ne
peuvent plus circuler librement ne
peuvent plus travailler librement près
de 4000 stations sont aujourd'hui en
manque en défaut de carburant en
empêchant nos compatriotes de vivre et
de travailler pleinement
madame la Première ministre vous avez
commencé par nier la gravité de la
situation
non non il n'y a pas de pénurie répété
il y a encore quelques jours monsieur
Véran rappelant ses déclarations
clairvoyantes et définitive sur
l'utilité des masques le président de la
République à lui a vu qu'une formule
tout aussi choquante refusée de
s'impliquer dans le conflit le faire
serait je le cite nous faire passer cul
par dessus tête on croit rêver on croit
rêvait face à un tel mépris face à un
tel déni de la difficulté des millions
de Français
une nouvelle fois oui une nouvelle fois
rien est anticipé rien n'est géré et les
Français ressentent légitimement le
sentiment que la France n'est plus
gouvernée face au blocage nous vous
demandons solennellement que le
gouvernement fasse preuve de
responsabilité et d'autorité
certes il est plus facile de limoger des
policiers que de s'opposer à la CGT pour
autant pour autant madame la Première
ministre quand allez-vous en fin de
débloquer cette situation en procédant
au réquisitions qui s'impose et que les
Français attendent merci beaucoup
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Eric Ciotti
la situation que vivent nos compatriotes
en particulier dans les hauts de France
et en Île-de-France et difficile
et difficile à certains endroits elle
est même insupportable et dans un
contexte où les incertitudes en matière
d'énergie sur notre quotidien collectif
cette situation crée des angoisses bien
au-delà des régions touchées par ce
conflit alors depuis le début alors
depuis le début du conflit social dans
les raffineries et les dépôts de
carburant le gouvernement a agi nous
avons renforcé l'approvisionnement des
stations services en mobilisant les
stocks stratégiques de l'État et en
augmentant les importations nous avons
autorisé à titre exceptionnel
l'ouverture des dépôts et les livraisons
pendant le week-end ces décisions ont
permis d'augmenter les livraisons dans
les zones en grande difficulté plus 50%
en Île-de-France plus 35% dans les hauts
de France par rapport à la normale
pour autant la persistance des grèves et
l'augmentation des achats de précaution
ont rendu la situation très difficile
pour de nombreux Français
hier soir au niveau national 30% des
stations étaient en rupture sur au moins
un produit avec de fortes disparités
géographiques entre régions entre
départements parfois d'une ville à
l'autre je mesure pleinement l'impact
sur la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens comme vous le savez j'ai
réuni hier les ministres concernés
j'ai eu par ailleurs à plusieurs
reprises les responsables des
confédérations syndicales et les
dirigeants des entreprises concernées
parce que je le précise s'agissant de
négocier son salariale ce sont d'abord
des sujets qui doivent se régler entre
la direction et les représentants des
salariés mais nous sommes en lien
constant avec les préfets nous sommes en
lien constant avec les préfets pour
faire le point sur les situations et je
veux saluer leur mobilisation et leur
réactivité j'ai par ailleurs échangé
avec le président de la région des Hauts
de France qui suit la situation de très
près alors quelle est cette situation
je voudrais le redire des désaccords sur
le rythme des négociations salariales on
conduit à des blocages dans des dépôts
pétroliers et des raffineries le
gouvernement appelle à la responsabilité
pour dialoguer un désaccord salarial ne
justifie pas de bloquer le pays refusé
de discuter c'est faire des Français les
victimes d'une absence de dialogue et je
vais être plus précise des accords sont
possibles il y a d'ailleurs eu un accord
majoritaire signé hier chez Esso
aujourd'hui une partie des organisations
malgré cet accord veut poursuivre le
mouvement et continuer le blocage nous
ne pouvons pas l'accepter
le dialogue social
le dialogue social s'est avancé dès lors
qu'une majorité s'est dégagée et ce ne
sont pas des accords à minimal et
propositions mises sur la table par la
direction de l'entreprise et
significative dès lors j'ai demandé au
préfet d'engager comme le permet la loi
la procédure de réquisition des
personnels indispensables au
fonctionnement des dépôts de cette
entreprise
chez Total les syndicats réformistes ont
appelé à l'ouverture de négociations la
direction a répondu favorablement
j'espère que les autres syndicats
représentatifs saisiront cette main
tendue car le dialogue social est
toujours plus fécond que le conflit à
défaut le gouvernement agira là encore
pour débloquer la situation lorsque la
porte est ouverte à la discussion
lorsque des discussions sont prêtes à
être discutées on ne peut pas continuer
à bloquer le pays chacun doit prendre
ses responsabilités le gouvernement
prend les siennes notre objectif est
clair nous voulons que la situation des
Français s'améliore rapidement
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
la parole est à madame la Présidente
panneau pour le groupe la France
insoumise
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre ko provocation violence blocage
quand la macronie est en déroute n'a
plus que ses quatre mots à la bouche
depuis des jours les salariés des
raffineries de groupe Total et exon sont
en grève des milliers de stations
services sont à sec Emmanuel Macron
l'irresponsable en chef l'affirme sans
scrupule la pénurie de carburant ne
serait pas du tout liée au gouvernement
à vous entendre vous ne seriez donc
responsable de rien pourtant le chaos
c'est vous les multinationales totales
et exon se gavent de milliards d'euros
de bénéfices pour arroser leurs
actionnaires 18 milliards en 6 mois pour
total 18 milliards en trois mois pour
exson mais vous refusez toujours de
taxer les super profits et de bloquer
les prix la provocation c'est vous
Patrick pouyanet PDG de Total s'est
augmenté de 52% pour gagner en un an
l'équivalent de 312 années de Smic mais
vous refusez toujours d'augmenter les
avec le soutien du rassemblement
national à vous entendre tandis que ceux
d'en haut sans graisse les salariés
devraient supporter l'indécence en
silence nul doute la violence sociale
c'est vous vous avez rejeté en bloc
toutes nos propositions depuis des mois
les salariés réclament désormais par la
lutte tout ce que vous leur avez refusé
au Parlement alors cessez votre
propagande anti grévistes car le blocage
c'est vous nous sommes solidaires de
tous les grévistes actuels et à venir
dans leur combat pour la justice sociale
et des millions de Français que vous
empêchez de circuler et de vivre madame
la Première ministre quand allez-vous
comprendre qu'avant d'appeler à
débloquer les dépôts il faudra débloquer
les salaires le dimanche 16 octobre
contre la panne sèche nous ferons le
plein dans la rue
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
alors madame la Présidente je rappelle
que l'appel au cas où à l'Assemblée et
dans la rue c'est vous
et je voudrais rajouter quelques points
complémentaires dont vous soulevez la
question des profits exceptionnels dans
certains secteurs
nous partageons cette préoccupation et
vous aurez l'occasion de débattre dans
le cadre du projet de loi de finance des
mesures qui sont proposées précisément
pour les entreprises du secteur des
énergies fossiles
vous préoccupez également et je partage
cette préoccupation de la situation des
salariés des entreprises de la
pétrochimie je dois vous dire que pour
ma part je me préoccupe aussi de la
situation des millions de Français qui
ne peuvent pas faire leur plein
je pense par exemple aux aides à
domicile qui ne peuvent pas les voir les
personnes âgées dont elles s'occupent je
pense au médecin qui ne peuvent pas
effectuer leur visite à domicile je
pense aux transports scolaire qui ne
peuvent pas être assurés dans certains
territoires je pense à la situation des
taxis et des VTC oui mesdames la
précédente c'est la ma première
préoccupation et cela d'autant plus que
le dialogue social est possible hier
chez So un accord majoritaire a été
trouvé aujourd'hui la direction de Total
répondant à la demande de syndicats
réformiste à proposer d'ouvrir des
négociations j'espère que les syndicats
l'ensemble des syndicats saisiront cette
main tendue alors c'est clair que le
dialogue social peut toujours
s'améliorer et que les situations de
blocage ne sont jamais le fait d'une
seule des parties mais en l'espèce les
entreprises sont prêtes au dialogue il
s'agit désormais de se mettre autour de
la table bloquer le pays n'est jamais
une façon d'avancer moi je crois au
social je crois à la possibilité de
déboucher sur des accords favorables aux
salariés je crois au sens des
responsabilités des uns et des autres la
demande des syndicats dont vous relayez
les motivations étaient claires
accélérez les négociations dans
l'entreprise cette revendication a été
satisfaite je veux donc vous dire madame
la Présidente que je crois dans ce
cas-là à certains principes notamment il
faut savoir terminer une grève dès lors
que la situation satisfaction a été
obtenue je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre madame la Présidente
madame la Première ministre nous avons
reçu une information selon laquelle le
gasoil d'import commandé par le
gouvernement aurait été raffiné à partir
d'un pétrole brut d'origine russe
confirmez-vous cette information et le
blocage pour les millions de Français
qui ne peuvent pas aller travailler
c'est vous
la parole est à Monsieur maths se le
faire pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté numérique
et industrielle hier notre assemblé a
débuté l'examen du budget pour 2023
enfin nous pouvons confronter nos
visions pour les finances et les
priorités de notre pays et démontrer
qu'entre le laxisme dénoncé par les uns
et l'austérité vilipendée par les autres
il y a une voie qui est celle de la
responsabilité
au fond face au défi immense auquel nous
sommes confrontés il y a quatre grandes
familles de solutions soit continuer à
nous endetter sans limite nous ne
faisons pas ce choix soit diminuer le
niveau de protection de nos compatriotes
face à l'inflation nous ne faisons pas
ce choix soit augmenter les impôts nous
ne faisons pas son choix soit maîtriser
nos dépenses et continuer à baisser les
impôts pour encourager le travail et
financer nos priorités c'est le choix
que nous faisons parce qu'il a déjà fait
ses preuves au service d'une promesse
que l'on avait même jamais osé faire à
ma notre génération de plein emploi
protection
protection et sérieux telles sont donc
les deux maîtres mots de ce projet de
budget protection des Français face à
l'inflation dans un contexte inédit avec
la poursuite du bouclier tarifaire la
baisse de plus de 6 milliards d'euros de
l'impôt sur le revenu et la protection
des plus modeste les faits sont têtus
mes chers collègues nous sommes le seul
pays de la zone euro ou l'inflation est
la plus basse et c'est grâce à la
majorité que nous l'avons obtenu et la
seule marche contre la vie chère qui
vaille mes chers collègues c'est celle
qui doit nous mener à l'adoption de ce
budget et rien d'autre sérieux en
refusant la double fatalité de
l'endettement et des hausses d'impôts
quand notre dette va franchir le cap
symbolique des 3000 milliards d'euros et
que nous sommes vice champion du monde
des prélèvements obligatoires alors ma
question monsieur le ministre est la
suivante pouvez-vous nous rappeler les
priorités de la majorité que financent
ce projet de budget tout en poursuivant
l'indispensable maîtrise de nos comptes
publics je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'Économie des Finances de
la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Lefebvre nous avons commencé avec le
ministre des comptes publics Gabriel
Attal hier l'examen de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques et
du budget pour 2023 les débats ont
commencé les débats vont durer et ils
dureront le temps nécessaire nous sommes
patients avec Gabriel Attal ouvert au
débat ouvert au dialogue et nous
prendrons le temps qu'il faudra
je note dans ces débats que vous avez
d'un côté ce qui nous dise vous n'avez
pas d'ambition suffisante sur la
réduction la dépense publique et la
réduction de la dette je leur dis bah
non ce cas là votez la loi de
programmation des finances publiques qui
nous permet de rétablir les finances
publiques qui nous permet de revenir sur
les 3 % de déficit et qui nous permet de
réduire la dette soyez cohérent mesdames
et messieurs les députés et de l'autre
côté de l'hémicycle nous avons des
parlementaires qui nous disent vous
faites preuve d'austérité
l'austérité à 100 milliards d'euros de
protection des Français ça fait cher
l'austérité et ça n'est pas ma
conception de ce que peut-être une
politique austéritaire la nôtre elle est
très simple et vous l'avez parfaitement
défini c'est de trouver un équilibre
entre la protection indispensable de nos
compatriotes
le bouclier contre la vie chère le
bouclier contre l'augmentation du prix
du gaz le bouclier contre l'augmentation
du prix de l'électricité nous avons fait
le choix avec la première ministre de
protéger les Français face à l'inflation
et à la vie chère nous avons le niveau
d'inflation le plus faible de la zone
euro et nous devrions en être fort et
nous ferons la même chose pour les
entrepreneurs pour les protéger face à
la flambée de leurs factures
énergétiques et de l'autre le
rétablissement des comptes publics car
oui il ne serait pas y avoir de
souveraineté industrielle ou économique
sont rétablissement des finances
publiques et sans réduction de la dette
nous tiendrons aussi cette ambition et
c'est en tenant fort ces deux autres
ambitions avec votre soutien que nous
servirons bien la France je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Thierry frappé
pour le groupe rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
de qui se moque-t-on vous demandez la
fin de l'abondance depuis cet été comme
si les Français en abusé vous
communiquez sur des pulls à coller en
prenant la sobriété énergétique en
demandant aux Français toujours plus
d'efforts avec moins de pouvoir d'achat
depuis plusieurs jours les stations
services de ma circonscription dans le
Pas-de-Calais sans toucher à plus de 50%
par la pénurie de carburant si je vais à
côté dans la Marne on en est aujourd'hui
à 74% de pénurie pour le gazole les
raisons sont simples et vous pouvez agir
nous avons d'un côté les salariés de
Total et exones qui demandent une
augmentation de salaire car le coût de
la vie est trop élevé et leur travail
estimé trop peu récompensé de l'autre
des millions de Français à qui vous
demandez de ne plus vivre en abondance
madame la Première ministre soyons
sérieux depuis bien des années les
Français ne plus en abondance et se
serre la ceinture pour finir leur moi
quand comprendrez-vous que les Français
ont peur pour le pouvoir d'achat peur de
ne plus joindre les deux bouts à la fin
du mois quand madame la Première
ministre allez-vous nous écouter et
diminuer la TVA sur le carburant jouer
sur la TICPE
le constat est simple depuis plusieurs
mois nos compatriotes accumulent les
difficultés inflation reproche
d'abondance pénurie de matières
premières maintenant pénurie de
carburant les Français entrent dans une
morosité quotidienne 74% des actifs ont
besoin de carburant pour travailler et
nombreux sont ceux qui ne peuvent pas
attendre ma question est simple que
comptez-vous faire face à cette pénurie
de carburant chez les Français qui en
subissent déjà assez quand passerez-vous
à l'action nous devons agir maintenant
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Véran porte-parole du
gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député Thierry frappé
le carburant du rassemblement national
on le connaît c'est la démagogie et là
et là vous ne faites jamais grève
et là vous me faites jamais grève
monsieur le buté la première ministre
viendrait répondre à deux interventions
que vous avez sans doute écouté parmi
lors de ces interventions elle a
expliqué les raisons et d'ailleurs vous
êtes revenu dessus sur ce conflit social
sur le souhait du gouvernement de
laisser le temps et la place au dialogue
social et lorsqu'on voit que ce dialogue
est bloqué lorsqu'on voit que les
positions sont tendues lorsqu'on voit
que les premières victimes ce sont les
Françaises et les Français qui veulent
légitimement pouvoir prendre leur
véhicule pour travailler pour amener
leurs enfants à l'école pour aller chez
le médecin ou faire ou pour des courses
il est normal que le gouvernement
intervienne dans la situation du groupe
Esso un accord majoritaire a été trouvé
un syndicat la CGT de conteste continue
de bloquer nous allons débloquer via des
réquisitions dans une autre situation il
était demandé à ce que des négociations
sur les salaires soient ouvertes le
groupe Total a répondu favorablement des
syndicats comme la CFDT ont répondu
favorablement le même syndicat la CGT a
décidé là aussi de bloquer avant même
que les négociations s'ouvrent à nouveau
si la situation ne devait pas bouger ce
qui a la première ministre a annoncé
c'est que le gouvernement prendra ses
resp rentabilité et procédera à des
réquisitions de l'essence nous en avons
du carburant nous en avons nous en avons
dans l'espace nous en avons dans les
centres de dépôt nous en avons dans les
raffineries ce carburant il doit pouvoir
sortir des dépôts et doit pouvoir sortir
des raffineries pour aller dans les
stations-service c'est ce qu'attendre de
nous les français et ce que nous allons
faire tout en respectant le dialogue
social c'est fondamental monsieur le
député après pardonnez-moi vous avez
parlé vous avez parlé de peur vous avez
parlé de morosité vous avez fait
l'amalgame habituel qu'on connaît bien
parce que la peur et la morosité sont
finalement les mamelles de l'extrême
droite permettez-moi de ne pas
m'inscrire dans ce débat que vous voulez
ouvrir je vous aurais fondu
factuellement pour le carburant nous
sommes du côté des Français de sa
décision de qui travaille et qui
attendent des solutions et non pas des
problèmes
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
je rappelle au groupe qu'il pose des
questions ou qu'il n'en posent pas qu'il
vaut mieux écouter les réponses un tant
soit peu dans le calme
monsieur Bertrand petit pour le groupe
socialiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Roland Lescure
ministre délégué chargé de l'Industrie
la huitième circonscription du
Pas-de-Calais que j'ai l'honneur de
représenter historiquement une terre
d'industrie je citerai arc France leader
mondial des airs de la table qui
emploient encore 5000 personnes les
nombreuses papeteries de Blendecques
visèrent noir Drake ou air sur la Lys
Aperam à Isbergues pour le secteur de la
métallurgie ou encore Faurecia Auchel
pour le secteur de l'automobile toutes
ces belles entreprises emploient
plusieurs milliers de salariés génèrent
autant d'emplois indirects et font vivre
tout un bassin de vie et toutes parce
qu'elles sont fortement consommatrices
de gaz et d'électricité sont directement
impactées et fragilisés par les coûts de
l'énergie qui ont explosé la situation
de trésorerie de ces entreprises
est-elle qu'elles n'ont malheureusement
pour la plupart pas d'autres choix que
d'avoir recours à du chômage partiel
suscitant une forte et légitime
inquiétude chez les salariés ces
familles de salariés subissent très
clairement une double peine entre
salaire rogné de 15 à 20% et un pouvoir
d'achat en berne en raison de
l'inflation galopante mais question sont
donc simples monsieur le ministre afin
de sauvegarder ses savoir-faire
industriels et surtout les milliers
d'emplois qui y sont attachés quelles
sont les mesures très concrètes que vous
entendez prendre pour répondre à
l'urgence de la situation et permettre à
ces entreprises d'honorer les factures
de gaz et d'électricité dont les
montants ont littéralement explosé
l'inquiétude est particulièrement
palpable chez arc France où vous vous
êtes récemment rendu et où vous avez
clairement réaffirmé le total soutien de
l'État ce dont je vous remercie une
nouvelle fois lorsque j'ai rencontré
leur syndicat le 13 septembre dernier
ils ont exprimés leur vives
interrogations sur l'avenir du groupe il
réclame une prise de participation
financière de l'État le temps de passer
cette période de fortes tensions et de
grandes turbulences y êtes-vous disposés
monsieur le ministre enfin en ce qui
concerne les salariés doublement
impactés car contraint de cesser leur
activité envisagez-vous une prise en
charge à 100% par l'état du chômage
partiel je vous remercie beaucoup la
parole est à Monsieur Bruno Le Maire
ministre de l'Économie des Finances de
la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique
monsieur le député je voudrais d'abord
dire que je partage totalement votre
inquiétude
et avec le ministre chargé de
l'Industrie Roland Lescure avec la
première ministre ils ont parfaitement
conscience que l'explosion des factures
énergétiques menaces tout notre tissu
industriel les grandes entreprises comme
les petites comme les PME comme les
entreprises de taille industrielle donc
nous sommes totalement mobilisés pour
éviter que la crise inflationniste
affaiblissent notre tissu industriel que
nous avons protégé pour la crise du
covid donc nous avons trois réponses
très concrètes la première c'est de
mettre sur pied à partir du 1er novembre
un fond de soutien pour les PME
industriels qui sera simplifiée et avec
des aides plus massives simplifiées
parce que il faut que le montant de
l'énergie qui est dépensé par rapport au
chiffre d'affaires d'entreprise je sais
pas calculer en 2021 mai en 2022 faut
que le bénéfice ne joue pas calculé sur
plusieurs mois mais dès que le bénéfice
commence à baisser il faut que nous
puissions soutenir les entreprises et
massifier parce que 2 millions d'euros
ça peut ne pas suffire pour certaines
entreprises nous avons donc demandé le
doublement les aides à 4,50 et 100
millions d'euros pour aider tout notre
tissu industriel ce guichet unique sera
ouvert le 1er novembre il sera simple il
sera massif et j'invite toutes les PME
industriels qui auraient du mal à régler
leurs factures à venir s'inscrire et à
toucher les aides auxquelles elles ont
droit la deuxième réponse c'est celle
qu'apporteront Lescure sur certaines
entreprises énergo intensives ça peut
être Arc International ça peut être
d'autres entreprises nous aurons des
réponses spécifiques taillées sur mesure
vous avez des entreprises industrielles
pour lesquelles la facture énergétique
se chiffre en millions d'euros il faut
un traitement individualisé Roland
Lescure rapportera un traitement
individualisé enfin je le rappelle la
vraie réponse de long terme pour
laquelle nous nous battons depuis
maintenant 14 mois avec le président de
la République c'est d'obtenir enfin le
découplage du prix du gaz et du prix de
l'électricité pour que nous ayons appris
l'électricité moins élevé et que tout
notre tissu industriel en France en
Europe soit protégé nous avançons la
bonne direction nous avons fait bouger
les lignes et nous urons jusqu'au bout
ce combat merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Thomas Meunier
pour le groupe horizon
[Musique]
on s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de
la santé et de la prévention monsieur le
ministre depuis 5 ans notre majorité
s'engage pour améliorer l'accès aux
soins des Français suppression du
numerus clausus doublement du nombre de
maisons de santé création des assistants
médicaux lancement de la
téléconsultation déploiement en cours du
service d'accès aux soins malgré cela
force est de constater que l'accès aux
soins figure au premier rang des
difficultés de nos concitoyens au
quotidien alors que vous avez lancé le
CNR santé au Mans la semaine dernière
que nous avons commencé l'examen de du
budget de la Sécurité sociale pour 2023
en commission le président de la
République a déclaré hier faire
confiance au Parlement pour répondre à
cet enjeu il a raison prise en charge de
certaines pathologies par les
pharmaciens infirmiers kinés
renouvellement de certains traitements
par les pharmaciens fin de l'intérim pas
besoin de nouvelles lois ces mesures
figurent dans la loi santé et de 2019
dont j'étais rapporteur et dans la loi
portée par ma collègue Stéphane iris il
s'agit maintenant de prendre les textes
réglementaires 17 décret très arrêté
reste en attente sur ces deux textes
nous pouvons agir sans attendre ici les
conclusions du CNR par ailleurs le
gouvernement ouvre la voie à la
régulation de l'installation des
médecins via le conventionnement
sélectif à travers le PLFSS c'est une
mesure que j'ai toujours considérée
comme inefficace le rapport chargé
produit de l'assurance maladie le prouve
et qui en plus fait payer le patient qui
ne serait plus remboursé en consultant
impatient un médecin des conventionné
seriez-vous à la place favorable à la
mesure que je propose vivant à notoriser
l'installation en zone surdenses qu'en
cas de remplacement d'un médecin cessant
son activité ou d'engagement d'une
activité en zone soudance enfin Monsieur
le Ministre 6 millions de nos
concitoyens n'ont pas de médecin
traitant aujourd'hui et ont une pénalité
financière dans leur parcours de soins
c'est une véritable doute bleue Pen et
c'est inacceptable seriez-vous prêt à
supprimer cette sanction comme le
propose le groupe horizon je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur François Braun
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Thomas
Meunier l'accès aux soins et plus
largement l'accès à la santé est un
enjeu majeur et je sais que beaucoup de
parlementaires sont concernés sur leur
territoire parce qu'on appelle les
déserts médicaux en tout cas l'inégalité
d'accès à la santé comme vous l'avez dit
nous avons déjà fait nous avons déjà agi
sur ces difficultés le numerus clausus
les investissements du Ségur en sont un
exemple il reste encore beaucoup à faire
et bien entendu la mise en application
des lois qui ont été votées dans cette
assemblée va se mettre en route et en
particulier comme je l'ai annoncé le
déplafonnement de l'intérim cannibale
c'est intérim qui met à mal nos services
et nos structures
[Musique]
sur la régulation à l'installation
nous avons fait des erreurs au cours de
ces 20 30 dernières années et beaucoup
d'entre vous étaient déjà dans cette
hémicycle pour valider entre autres le
numerus clausus et il est bon que nous
soyons revenus là-dessus comme je l'ai
dit il n'y a pas de sujet tabou
mais j'ai avant tout une recherche de
l'efficacité des mesures qui seront
prises avec surtout éviter que ces
mesures et les effets inverse à ce que
l'on attend il n'y a pas de solution
miracle mais nous devons nous baser sur
les bras qui existent encouragés nos
médecins à rester plus longtemps
favoriser la découverte et
l'installation de nos jeunes confrères
dans les territoires sous dotés par le
guichet unique ou la quatrième année
augmenter le temps médical pour que
chacun apporte son utilité dans les
parcours de soins que ce soit par
diminuer la bureaucratie augmenter les
transferts de tâches et compétences ce
que j'ai demandé aux ordres
professionnels j'attends leur réponse
mais le gouvernement sera prendre ses
responsabilités sur ces transferts de
tâches merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Aurélien taché pour le groupe écologiste
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre chers collègues la
situation nouvelle en Ukraine nécessite
désormais une position claire de la
France une position claire parce que
plus de 80 missiles ont été tirés hier
sur des infrastructures énergétiques des
habitations et même des aires de jeux
pour enfants ils ont fait 19 morts et
plus de 100 blessés et se poursuivent
aujourd'hui à Lille ces actes portent un
nom celui de crime de guerre Poutine
doit être ainsi être traitée pour ceux
qui l'est un criminel de guerre
mes chers collègues les Ukrainiens
lancent aujourd'hui le cri du désespoir
l'appel de la dernière chance ils ont
besoin de plus d'armes et notamment de
vrais systèmes de défense entière aérien
afin de protéger les populations civiles
des bombardements aveugles de l'armée
russe allons-nous entendre ces demandes
et prendre notre part si l'Ukraine prend
le dessus sur l'armée de Vladimir
Poutine elle le doit d'abord au courage
de son peuple mais jusqu'à quand
pourront-ils tenir alors que la
Biélorussie semble elle aussi décidé à
entrer en guerre quand visage
concrètement la France pour faire face à
ce nouveau belligérant le temps des
hésitations est passé madame la Première
ministre il faut agir une position
claire aussi parce que semaine après
semaine l'escalade guerrière du criminel
Poutine ne cesse de grandir hier et
aujourd'hui avec des bombardements
barbares la semaine d'avant avec les
référendums d'annexion l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies vient
d'ailleurs d'être saisie pour se
prononcer sur leur légalité et l'on voit
que de nombreux pays au Moyen-Orient ou
en Afrique hésitent sur la conduite à
tenir quand va-t-on comprendre que nos
échecs en Afrique notre comportement au
Moyen-Orient nous fournissons des armes
aux agresseurs du Yémen et notre
attitude discriminante vis-à-vis de
certains réfugiés sont bien sûr lié au
fossé qui se creusent chaque jour avec
les pays du Sud et qui permettent à
Poutine de se proclamer en hypothétique
chef d'un axe maliné une position claire
enfin parce que la situation de nos
entreprises toujours présentes en Russie
je le disais la semaine dernière a
clairement évolué avec la nouvelle loi
russe sur la mobilisation partielle vous
le savez cette loi oblige désormais nos
entreprises à collaborer directement
avec l'armée russe nous n'avons aucun
état des lieux précis des entreprises
françaises exercent toujours une
activité sur le sol russe et nous
permettant de connaître leur niveau de
participation volontaire ou non à la
mobilisation des traités par Poutine
madame la Première ministre seront nous
enfin à la hauteur de l'histoire
allons-nous enfin apporter de l'aide
dans l'Ukraine a besoin et dire stop au
profit du sang et de la honte merci
merci beaucoup la parole est à Madame
Catherine Colonna ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
tâché
hier et ce jour dans une moindre mesure
la Russie a de manière totalement
délibérée ciblée des zones et des
infrastructures civiles dans le simple
but de semer la peur dans une population
qui se bat pour sa liberté le droit
international est clair le président de
la République l'a déjà dit je le répète
devant vous frapper délibérément des
civils c'est un crime de guerre la
Russie devra en rendre compte ces actes
s'ajoutent au crime déjà révélés à bout
de chat irpin
izum Mario Paul et ailleurs en Ukraine
en ce moment même le président de la
République est réuni avec ces homologues
du G7 en présence du président ukrainien
Zelinski
cette réunion urgente nécessaire
permettra de rappeler notre unité notre
détermination à soutenir l'Ukraine pour
qu'elle puisse assurer sa défense
militaire et sa défense civile la France
il prend toute sa part monsieur le
député vous le savez bien et ces
matériels font souvent la différence sur
le terrain à l'approche de l'hiver nous
aiderons aussi ce pays à faire face aux
destructions qu'il subit à renforcer sa
résilience civile 200 millions d'aides
humanitaires ont déjà été mobilisées
allant de la répartie de la réparation
d'infrastructures à la livraison
d'équipements de sécurité civile vous
vous souvenez sans doute qu'un bateau
chargé de 1000 tonnes de fraise
humanitaires dont des équipements
humanitaires dont des biens de première
nécessité dont des ponts dont des
matériaux de construction et partie de
Marseille il y a quelques jours est
arrivé en Roumanie et les chargements se
dirigent vers l'Ukraine dans le même
temps nous voulons que la Russie
comprenne qu'elle est dans une impasse
elle est dans une impasse en armée
recule sur le terrain son économie
recule sa diplomatie recule comme nous
le verrons monsieur le député demain à
l'Assemblée générale des Nations Unies
sur le vote tant attendu concernant les
annexes auxquelles la Russie a procédé
sur des territoires Ukrainiens la Russie
a choisi la guerre elle doit choisir de
sortir de cet impasse et de restaurer
l'intégrité territoriale de l'Ukraine je
vous remercie je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Erwan Balan pour le groupe démocrate la
présidente mes chers collègues la
semaine dernière les jeunes femmes
iraniennes retirant leur voile dans leur
établissement scolaire nous ont
impressionné par leur courage et leur
détermination
ces actes de bravoure force notre
admiration et nous inspire en cette
journée internationale des droits des
filles il nous questionne et nous
rappelle qu'il reste encore beaucoup à
faire pour les filles dans le monde une
fille sur 5 a subi un viol ou une
agression sexuelle et chaque année plus
de 12 millions de filles sont mariés de
force soit un mariage forcé toutes les
deux secondes en France
82% des femmes ont été victimes de
harcèlement de rue avant l'âge de 17 ans
et pour une femme sur six l'entrée dans
la sexualité se fait par un rapport non
consenti et non désiré
ces chiffres nous montrent nous le
montre les jeunes filles sont
particulièrement victimes de violences
et d'agressions physiques ou
psychologique ces violences laissent le
plus souvent des marques indélébiles des
cicatrices qui entravent le
développement des filles durant la
précédente législature nous avons avancé
et plusieurs lois votées protègent mieux
nos enfants mais il nous reste tant à
faire j'ai la conviction que c'est par
la connaissance de leurs droits que nos
enfants et en particulier les filles
pourront s'épanouir dans notre société
alors l'éducation civique et l'éducation
sexuelle doivent devenir des
incontournables des programmes scolaires
pour que chaque enfant apprenne à se
comporter dans le respect de soi et des
autres
chaque jeune fille doit pouvoir savoir
qu'elle a le droit de dire non qu'elle
est libre d'être qui elle est fier de
revendiquer ses droits fier de s'engager
et fier de choisir son parcours de vie
madame la ministre
Elisabeth Rome je souhaiterais donc
connaître les prochaines étapes de votre
action pour permettre à toutes les
filles de notre pays d'être pleinement
maîtresse de leur destin
merci beaucoup la parole est à madame
Isabelle Rome ministre délégué chargé de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
de la diversité de l'égalité des chances
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député Erwan Balanant un peu partout
dans le monde les cris des filles et des
femmes s'élèvent aujourd'hui pour la
liberté et l'égalité en cette Journée
internationale de la fille je
commencerai par rappeler l'attachement
un défectible de la France au droit des
filles et des femmes un attachement qui
se traduit notamment à travers notre
diplomatie féministe mais aussi à
travers les nombreuses mesures que nous
avons déployées depuis 2017 qu'il
s'agisse de l'accès aux droits ou de la
protection des victimes nous allons
aussi mettre les moyens financiers
supplémentaires en faveur des plans
d'action pour l'éducation à l'égalité
les violences et les inégalités sans
racines dès l'enfance comme vous l'avez
souligné monsieur le député il est
essentiel que dès le plus jeune âge la
culture de l'égalité soit diffusée avec
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
nous veillerons à la stricte application
de la loi de 2001 il est nécessaire
d'accompagner les chefs d'établissement
et les enseignants afin qu'ils
s'emparent de l'éducation à la sexualité
et c'est à cette fin que nous irons avec
Papen Ndiaye jeudi dans un établissement
de la région parisienne mesdames et
messieurs les députés chaque fille a le
droit à une vie sans violence chaque
fille a le droit à l'égalité chaque
fille doit avoir voie au chapitre c'est
le combat de ce gouvernement et de la
majorité je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la ministre la parole
ça monsieur Guy Brico pour le groupe
yote merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre le maire alors je suis d'autres
députés de la région des Hauts de France
et mes concitoyens ne comprendraient pas
que je n'intervienne pas sur ce sujet
depuis une semaine ils sont confrontés
une pénurie de carburant ils sont
exaspérés comme beaucoup de mes
collègues je ne cesse d'être contacté
par de nombreux professionnels par de
nombreuses personnes qui font parfois
des queues de plusieurs centaines de
mètres et qui arrivaient à la pompe
constate qu'il n'y a plus de carburant
et quand elles en trouvent il a
considérablement augmenté cela s'ajoute
à l'augmentation générale du coût de la
vie se sont encore les plus fragiles qui
vont payer le prix fort
que dire à celui qui doit prendre sa
voiture pour se rendre sur son lieu de
travail et je ne parle pas des problèmes
que cela
occasionne aux agriculteurs aux
industriels et à l'ensemble du secteur
économique ils font preuve pour
l'instant de beaucoup de patience mais
jusqu'à quand il souffre ils en ont
marre déjà le 5 octobre la Fédération
nationale des transporteurs routiers
tirer la sonnette d'alarme chez moi dans
le code réside toutes les stations
étaient où sont fermées sauf quelques
livraisons épisodiques
on nous dit qu'il y a du carburant dans
les dépôts de la région alors pourquoi
ne pas réquisitionner vous en avez parlé
le droit de grève même si on le respecte
ne devrait pas permettre d'entraver
toutes l'économie d'un pays comme
souvent vous avez sous-estimé l'impact
pour les Français en passant que la
situation s'améliorerait rapidement ma
question que comptez-vous faire pour que
l'avenir de telles situations ne se
reproduise plus aura-t-on un jour une
vision à long terme gouverner c'est
prévoir
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de
l'écologie et de la cohésion des
territoires
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre monsieur le député
Brico d'abord merci de vous faire avec
les mots que vous avez choisi le
porte-parole de tous ces Français
anonymes qui sont les victimes de ce
blocage lié à un dialogue social qui a
pris une forme qui n'est pas acceptable
c'est celui d'un blocage préventif des
dépôts au lieu d'avoir une discussion
qui dans une démocratie et qui dans un
système barritaire doit d'abord reposer
et laisser sa chance à la discussion
entre direction et syndicats le
gouvernement a pris ses responsabilités
de manière successive d'abord ça a été
dit en laissant le temps du dialogue
puis en laissant du dieu le temps du
dialogue et en réquisitionnant les
stocks stratégiques puis en autorisant
les camions à circuler pour
réapprovisionner les séries les
différentes stations et l'augmentation
n'a pas permis d'arriver à un retour
d'une situation satisfaisante parce
qu'en parallèle les achats de précaution
ont compensé les approvisionnements
nouveaux qui avaient été fait
dans ces conditions malgré les appels au
dialogue renouvelés nous sommes
aujourd'hui devant une situation dans la
première ministre a il y a quelques
minutes tirer les conclusions après
avoir réuni autour d'elle hier les
ministres concernés
le constat que dans une de ces deux
entreprises les syndicats ont obtenu un
accord majoritaire et que rien n'a bougé
et que dans l'autre la grève continue à
constituer une forme de pression sur le
dialogue social ne sont pas des
situations acceptables pour des millions
de Français dont vous vous êtes fait le
porte-parole et il y a un instant dans
ces conditions ce que la première
ministre a dit et que je ne peux que
redire c'est que elle a demandé au
préfet d'engager les procédures qui
permettront de réquisitionner les
personnels qui continuent de bloquer ses
dépôts le dialogue oui la discussion oui
le blocage non
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
monsieur Bricout j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour vous mais n'avez-vous pas
déclaré vendredi dernier la situation
devrait continuer à s'améliorer ça n'est
pas le cas et je vous invite à venir
discuter avec ceux qui pendant deux
heures durant font la queue pour arriver
je le répète à une pompe vide
éventuellement et vous comprendrez mieux
leurs détresse je vous remercie monsieur
le député la parole est à Monsieur
Quentin bataillon pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre délégué chargé des
transports monsieur le ministre sur ces
banc et avec vous nous travaillons
activement pour mettre fin à la
dépendance de la France au pétrole et
déployer avec les élus locaux partout
sur nos territoires des transports
collectifs et des transports doux
cependant aujourd'hui des dizaines de
millions de Français n'ont pas d'autres
choix que celui d'utiliser leur voiture
ou leur moto pour se déplacer or depuis
plusieurs jours nous assistons tous dans
nos circonscriptions au spectacle
désolant des longues files d'attente
devant les stations-service chez moi
dans la Loire à Saint-Étienne c'est déjà
plus d'une heure d'attente devant ses
stations services je veux aussi dire le
désarroi le désarroi des gérants des
stations services qui ne peuvent plus
commander des sens depuis plusieurs
jours que ma saint-pri en jarret
également dans la Loire
monsieur le ministre des Français ne
peuvent plus aller travailler des
agriculteurs ne peuvent plus produire
des professionnels de santé ne veulent
plus exercer leur mission vitale pour le
pays l'inquiétude monte et pour répondre
à la France insoumise l'inquiétude ce
qui peine ce ne sont pas les bourgeois
qui sont paniqués car les bourgeois
puent pour la plupart peuvent souvent
être télétravaillés ils peuvent choisir
d'autres modes de transport ce qui
paniquent aujourd'hui ce sont les
employés ce sont les ouvriers qui n'ont
pas d'autres choix qui n'ont pas d'autre
choix que d'utiliser leur véhicules pour
aller travailler et c'est à eux que nous
pensons combien de temps encore combien
de temps encore les cartes scolaires les
ambulances les camions de pompiers les
transporteurs de marchandises
pourront-ils circuler cette situation
nous ne devons pas la quantité d'essence
encore moins aux aides que nous avons
voté face à l'inflation
nous la devons ce nouveau concept qui
s'appelle la guerre préventive
c'est-à-dire bloquée avant d'écouter
bloquer avant de dialoguer bloquer avant
de négocier j'ai même envie de dire
bloquer avant de respecter
car bloqué c'est prendre en otage
prendre en otage le reste de la France
ma question est simple quand en faire le
gouvernement face à cette situation
inacceptable le ministre Bruno Le Maire
a ouvert la voie
allons-nous réquisitionner
je vous remercie monsieur le député la
parole est à monsieur Clément bonne
ministre délégué chargé des transports
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Quentin bataillon comme vous comme la
rappeler le gouvernement nous pensons
d'abord en effet à ces millions de
Français ces millions de familles ces
millions de travailleurs qui depuis
quelques jours vivent une situation
extrêmement difficile à cause d'une
minorité qui préfère le blocage au
dialogue nous laisserons pas faire nous
avons agi depuis le départ nous avons
laissé une chance au dialogue social et
comme l'indiqué la première ministre ou
prendrons en effet les mesures de
réquisition ciblées nécessaires pour
mettre fin à cette situation là où le
dialogue n'a pas été saisi après l'avoir
laissé la porte ouverte le plus
longtemps possible car c'était aussi
notre responsabilité votre majorité
notre majorité agit depuis 5 ans pour
protéger pour relancer notre économie
pour créer des emplois nous ne pouvons
pas laisser ces efforts ruinés par une
stratégie de blocage et comme vous
l'avez dit d'un nouveau concept étonnant
la grève préventive c'est pour eux c'est
pour ces Français que nous agissons
permettez-moi aussi de dire que depuis
le départ Christophe Béchu la rappelait
l'instant nous avons agi pour que cette
situation fasse au blocage de une
situation sociale aussi difficile soit
la moins pénalisante possible pour ceux
qui en avaient le plus besoin nous avons
pris des mesures pour que les camions
puissent circuler le week-end nous avons
débloqué avec Agnès les stocks
stratégiques de carburant aujourd'hui le
faut agir plus fort et plus vite nous
n’hésitons pas le faire comme la levons
annoncée depuis le départ et comme la
rappeler la première ministre
permettez-moi aussi monsieur le député
de rendre hommage aux professionnels du
secteur routier qui ont assuré malgré la
difficulté malgré leur propre difficulté
l'approvisionnement de notre pays le
transport de nos enfants dans les bus
scolaires il y a des endroits où c'est
difficile ou aujourd'hui c'est bloqué
c'est aussi une des raisons pour
lesquelles nous devons agir mais j'ai
échanger chaque jour avec eux ils ont
fait d'un grand courage une grande
détermination et je veux aussi saluer
cet engagement et cette résilience vous
avez raison monsieur le député ce n'est
pas la bourgeoisie qui craint les grèves
comme on l'entend sur les bancs de la
France insoumise vous la protéger très
bien merci pour elle nous agissons pour
les travailleurs les agissons pour ceux
qui veulent travailler nous agissons
pour ceux qui ont besoin aujourd'hui des
transports du quotidien pour mener leur
vie et ne pas être bloqué
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Fabien Roussel
pour le groupe GDR
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre parlons de travail après 35 ans
d'ancienneté à arc France un ouvrier ne
perçoit qu'un salaire de 1448 euros net
par mois il est posté 5 heures 13 heures
8 heures de boulot avec 30 minutes de
pause et deux fois 10 minutes de pause
pipi pour survivre il est obligé de
demander à la CAF sa prime d'activité et
il a le droit à la location de rentrée
scolaire et au chèque énergie mais pour
lui et ce sont ces mots ce n'est pas
digne
idem pour ce couvreur zingueur qualifié
âgé de 30 ans il travaille 45 heures par
semaine il touche 1400 euros de net par
mois il va arrêter ça paye pas me dit-il
et puis il y a ce couple de 45 ans
vivant dans un pavillon dans un petit
village de chez moi
3262 euros par mois pour deux entre les
prêts les études des enfants et les
factures qui augmentent le déficit et de
600 euros par mois il y a aussi tous ces
agriculteurs qui démissionnent chez eux
aussi le travail ne paye plus
puis il y a ce salarié de Total en grève
1366 euros de net par mois pas 5000
euros lui aussi doit compter sur la CAF
la prime d'activité payée par nos impôts
pendant que son patron distribue 2
milliards 5 de dividendes et s'augmente
de 52 % et il faudrait qu'il se taisent
ces hommes et ses femmes sont la fierté
de la nation il travaille dur il se lève
tôt et derrière eux il y a des vies des
familles ils ne veulent pas la charité
ils veulent être respectés et pour
débloquer la situation chez Total et
pour les Français ce ne sont pas les
salariés qu'il faut réquisitionner ce
sont les patrons de Total et des sceaux
pour qu'ils augmentent les salaires
c'est ce qui est demandé madame la
Première ministre la France est riche
mais les travailleurs sont pauvres alors
les députés communistes et GDR vous
demandent de convoquer une conférence
salariale pour placer les entreprises
face à leur responsabilité et indexer
les salaires sur l'inflation je vous
remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
au ministre du Travail du plein emploi
et de l'insertion merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Roussel comme
vous je suis élu d'une circonscription
industrielle et comme vous je connais
les Françaises et les Français qui
travaillent qui aiment l'industrie qui
aiment ce qu'ils font et qui souhaitent
vivre dignement de leur travail et comme
vous à écouter votre question je
comprends le sentiment que vous exprimez
lorsque vous dites que ces mêmes
français vous disent je veux vivre de
mon travail je ne veux pas la charité et
comme vous je préfère l'émancipation par
les salaires plutôt que par les
allocations nous avons la chance d'avoir
un système protecteur vous l'avez décrit
la prime d'activité vous en avez dit
vous avez dit votre sentiment elle
permet de protéger et d'augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat des Français nous avons
un système de protection sociale qui
fait envia beaucoup et c'est une fierté
que nous devons défendre nous avons mis
en place des outils pour répondre à la
question du pouvoir d'achat je ne
reviens pas sur les mesures votées
encore cet été le bouclier tarifaire les
aides au ménage les plus fragiles autant
d'engagement de l'état de la puissance
publique qui permettent de protéger les
Français comme aucun peuple en Europe
nous avons aussi mis en place des
dispositifs de partage de la valeur
partage de la valeur avec la
facilitation de l'intéressement avec la
prime exceptionnelle d'activité avec la
prime de pouvoir d'achat autant de
dispositifs qui permettent d'intéresser
les salariés aux fruits de leur travail
et vous savez monsieur le député que les
salariés qui bénéficient de ces primes
et ses accords d'intéressement en sont
heureux parce qu'ils participent aussi
au partage des richesses qu'il produit
et puis vous nous interrogez aussi sur
la question des salaires et ça me permet
de rappeler deux choses d'abord le fait
que nous avons un système de protection
du salaire minimum qui est unique avec
une indexation qui non seulement porte
sur l'inflation mais sur l'inflation du
premier quintile ce qui explique avec
une inflation de 6%, le SMIC a été
revalorisé eu de 8% depuis un an et cela
pour ces conséquences de motiver de
mobiliser le dialogue social dans les
branches le dialogue social dans les
branches nous le boostons pardon pour
cette expression nous l'accompagnons
vous avez vous-même le simplement à
voter une disposition qui accélère
encore les négociations lorsque des
minimas conventionnels sont encore entre
du SMIC il faut continuer ce dialogue
social faire en sorte que les salaires
soient plus dynamiques et nous l'avons
dit y compris avec le ministre de
l'Économie quand les entreprises peuvent
elles doivent augmenter les salaires et
nous les accompagnons les incitons pour
le faire merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à monsieur Alexandre
Loubet pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de
l'économie Bruno Le Maire Monsieur le
Ministre excelia est une société
française spécialisée dans
l'électronique de haute performance qui
équipe nos forces aériennes aérospatiale
et navales mais aussi des industries de
pointe comme les radars ou les IRM
médicaux elle dispose de 2000 salariés
de plusieurs sites industriels en France
et dans le monde et d'incarner de
commandes remplies après avoir été
abandonné à une société britannique
lorsqu'Emmanuel Macron était ministre de
l'Économie excelia pourrait être racheté
désormais par un groupe américain est
tombé notamment sous l'extra
territorialité du droit américain le
nouveau pillage de ce fleuron
s'inscrirait dans une série de trahisons
industrielle commise par Emmanuel Macron
Alstom Alcatel technique Lafarge la
tequwear Photonis Souriau age
vous avez bradé vous avez bradé à des
intérêts étrangers des centaines de
milliers d'emplois des centaines de
brevets notre génie industriel fruit du
travail de génération de français
monsieur le ministre je suis élu dans
une circonscription en Moselle dont les
hommes l'histoire et la terre ont
participé de la puissance industrielle
du pays puissance à laquelle vous avez
renoncé pour retrouver notre
souveraineté industriel la France doit
recourir au décret Montebourg face aux
prédations étrangères elle doit
également instaurer comme le propose
Marine Le Pen un véritable fond
souverain français qui oriente épargne
des Français vers le soutien à
l'industrie alors Monsieur le Maire ma
question est simple quand cessez-vous de
trahir les intérêts de la France
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
merci le député Loubet pour que la
France protège sa souveraineté
industrielle il faut d'abord protéger
les industries françaises contre la
flambée des prix de l'énergie vous
proposez de baisser la TVA de 25,5 c'est
15% de réduction il resterait 75% de
factures à payer nous nous avons pris en
charge 100% de la facture pour les plus
petits entreprises
pour reconquérir la souveraineté
industrielle mais je le député doubé
encore faut-il que nous soyons
compétitifs soyez impôts de production
par rapport à notre voisin allemand nous
avons baissé les impôts de production
vous avez refusé de voter la baisse des
impôts de production nous proposons de
supprimer la VAE 8 milliards d'impôts
qui pèsent principalement sur les PME
industriels le rassemblement national
refuse de supprimer la contribution à la
valeur ajoutée sur les entreprises
industrielles
vous nous parlez d'investissement
étrangers en France nous avons renforcé
par la loi le décret son investissement
étranger en France le rassemblement
national refuse de soutenir la
modification du décret sur les
investissements étrangers en France
alors le rassemblement national a
toujours de grands mots mais est
incapable de prendre de grandes
décisions
et champion pour susciter les polémiques
mais incapable de tenir de lignes fermes
continuent pour défendre notre
souveraineté industrielle cette majorité
elle a eu le courage de prendre les
décisions nécessaires plus d'emprunts
industriels c'est la première fois
depuis 20 ans plus d'entreprises
industrielles qui ouvrent que
l'entreprise industrielle qui ferme
c'est la première fois depuis 20 ans un
pays qui est redevenu le pays le plus
attractif pour les investissements
étrangers et pour la création d'emploie
industriels c'est la France c'est grâce
à la politique de cette majorité et
c'est grâce à la conscience de notre
ligne économique
merci beaucoup monsieur Loubet
Monsieur le Maire vous avez travaillé il
fut un temps pour Dominique de Villepin
qui avait dénoncé la lâcheté de ceux qui
refusent de défendre les intérêts de la
France aujourd'hui le lâche c'est vous
bonjour
j'ai l'honneur de demander des excuses
solennelles au rassemblement national
pour avoir employé le terme de lâche à
une personne qui a toujours fait preuve
de courage dans son engagement politique
depuis 20 ans qu'il fait de la politique
au service de la France et des Français
je vous remercie
mes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie de reprendre le calme
on va laisser
aller on va poursuivre les débats on va
laisser le groupe rassemblement national
quitter l'émission madame la députée
Félicie Gérard
vous avez la parole pour le groupe
horizon
merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
madame la ministre le 9 mai 2021 le
président de la République proposé dans
l'hémicycle du Parlement européen de
renforcer les coopérations européennes
et de créer à l'échelle de notre
continent une instance de dialogue entre
nations
jeudi dernier à Prague s'est tenu le
premier sommet de la communauté
politique européenne cette communauté
politique comprenant 44 nations de notre
continent est un véritable succès
diplomatique
regroupant des membres et nos membres de
l'Union européenne elle est un
formidable outil pour bâtir une
stratégie et créer des projets communs
lors de ce sommet historique dans la
période troublée que nous connaissons
ces tenu une réunion entre le Président
de la République le président du Conseil
européen Charles Michel le Premier
ministre arménien et le président dedans
l'Arménie et laser badjan sont en
conflit frontalier depuis des années un
conflit qui a connu de nombreuses
évolutions notamment depuis 2020 et plus
récemment lors d'un bombardement
déclenché par l'AS des badjan sur les
positions arméniennes les 12 et 13
septembre dernier
la Réunion inédite qui a eu lieu sous
l'impulsion du Président de la
République à Prague la semaine dernière
aura permis des avancées significatives
tout d'abord en réenfirmant de la part
de donation la reconnaissance mutuelle
de leur frontières mais également en
accent l'envoi d'une mission civile
européenne il est symboliquement fort de
voir aujourd'hui la France prendre le
rôle depuis puissance pacificatrice dans
le Caucase et plus largement en Europe
madame la ministre pouvons-nous en
savoir plus sur les objectifs de cette
mission ainsi que le rôle qui jouera la
France par ailleurs à l'heure où le
conflit
ukrainien prend une nouvelle ampleur
comment la France compte-t-elle poursuit
son rôle de puissance médiatrice en
Europe je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Catherine colonnat ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères merci madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Gérard je vous
remercie de votre question qui me permet
de faire le suivi de ce que j'avais dit
devant vous mardi dernier la France est
pleinement solidaire de l'Arménie face
aux violations de son intégrité
territoriale et elle agit madame la
députée depuis le début c'est-à-dire
depuis les frappes du 13 septembre notre
pays s'est mobilisé pour stabiliser la
situation sur le terrain pour demander
le retour des forces azerbaïdjanaises
sur leur position initiale et pour
accompagner la reprise des négociations
entre les deux pays le sommet que vous
évoquez organisé par le Président de la
République française en marge de la
réunion de la communauté politique
européenne donc à Prague le 6 octobre
a permis de réunir le président de la
République le président du Conseil
européen le président d'Arménie le
président d'Azerbaïdjan et ça permet
d'aboutir à des résultats importants un
accord a été obtenu un accord a été
obtenu sur la mise en place d'ici la fin
du mois sur le territoire arménien d'une
mission civile de l'Union européenne
pour une durée de 2 mois le long de la
frontière
l'objectif de cette mission est de
stabiliser la situation et d'engager un
processus entre les parties nous
souhaitons en particulier que cette
mission puisse contribuer au processus
de délimitation de la frontière qui va
être relancé et ceci dans les tous
prochains jours en parallèle nous
travaillons à la mise en place d'une
mission d'établissement des faits de
l'OSCE je vous en avais parlé pour
fournir un constat objectif de la
situation et des besoins notamment des
besoins humanitaires à la suite des
affrontements vous le savez madame la
députée mesdames et messieurs les
députés l'Arménie peut compter sur le
soutien de la France nous œuvrons pour
la paix dans son intérêt je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Gabriel Amar
pour le groupe LFI
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre
le magazine mariage a publié une enquête
pour le moins édifiante
alors que nous venons de connaître une
terrible sécheresse alors que les nappes
phréatiques ne sont pas rechargées alors
que les agriculteurs ont besoin d'eau la
présidence de la République
envisagerait rien de moins que de
troquer 4 milliards de mètres cubes
d'eau par an contre des hydrocarbures
résumons l'affaire après les réunions en
petit comité
l'Elysée semblerait envisager d'exporter
l'eau utilisée par la centrale
hydroélectrique de Saint-Chamas
aujourd'hui
cette centrale fonctionne à 50%. les
temps de Berre ne pouvant absorber plus
de volume au risque de voir son
écosystème remarquable mise en péril il
n'est donc pas envisageable de
multiplier par deux le volume transitant
par ce barrage sauf à étudier
sérieusement l'utilisation de l'eau pour
des usages indispensables aux habitants
et à l'agriculture alors madame le
Premier ministre alors que les tensions
sur la ressource en eau sont se sont
généralisés dans le pays pouvez-vous
nous assurer
que vous avez complètement et
définitivement abandonner ce projet
incroyable en attendant nous nous
marcherons à Paris ce dimanche 16
octobre contre votre inaction climatique
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires merci madame la Présidente
la première ministre monsieur le Gabriel
ama monsieur le député Gabriel Amar si
vous avez prévu de marcher dimanche
prochain uniquement contre ce projet
annulez votre marche parce que ce projet
n'aura pas lieu
à la fin du mois de septembre
à la fin du mois de septembre le
magazine Marianne a effectivement fait
état de rencontre qui se sont tenus
entre des porteurs de projets et des
conseillers ce projet n'a pas franchi la
barrière des conseillers et en aucune
manière nous ne l'envisageons en
revanche puisque vous évoquez ce sujet
permettez-moi de vous dire que le 29
septembre dernier j'étais sur les temps
de Berre en compagnie du député Pierre
d'arriville en compagnie du président
Jean-Marc duesy et en associant Eric
Diard évidemment à cette visite compte
tenu de la mission parlementaire qu'ils
ont tous les trois réalisé qui a été de
nature à modifier en profondeur
l'état j'allais dire de la synergie
nécessaire pour régler ce problème les
temps de mer vous l'avez dit c'est la
plus grande lagune d'Europe c'est 15000
hectares et on est dans une situation
paradoxale ou nous ne pouvons pas faire
tourner notre usine hydroélectrique
parce que trop d'eau potable dans cette
lune provoque des dégâts sur la
biodiversité trois options continuez à
diminuer la production hydraulique
acheminer de l'eau salée pour diluer
l'eau potable ou et c'est exactement la
solution que on mérite saint Chama avec
Bérengère Couillard en présence des
députés d'arriville et zoulesi nous
avons poussé au contraire examiner deux
options ou la réutilisation de cette eau
potable notamment contenu de l'été que
nous avons vécu en particulier avec
l'écosystème de la plaine du Crau ou
regardez comment cette eau potable
pourrait réalimenter l'usine
hydroélectrique avec une forme de
circuit fermé comme ça peut exister dans
certains endroits pour soutenir une
forme d'énergie renouvelable
en liaison avec les collectivités
locales avec le gyprebe avec la
métropole d'Aix-Marseille avec la région
sud évidemment avec EDF nous travaillons
à ces hypothèses merci beaucoup
[Musique]
monsieur
le ministre parce que l'eau c'est la vie
et la vie n'est pas avant je voudrais
juste ajouter par rapport à l'hypothèse
auquel vous faites référence que je
crois que le coût à visueux avoisine 2
milliards d'euros et que j'aimerais bien
qu'on le mette au regard de ce qui
pourrait être fait pour recharger des
nappes phréatiques recharger des
rivières et d'autres zones qui ont
besoin de profiter aux habitations en
eau douce je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Julien dive pour le groupe les
républicains
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur Miss
de l'éducation nationale plutôt latin ou
grec peut-être arts plastiques langue
des signes ou encore EPS les options
sont plus ou moins variées selon les
lycées qu'il soit littéraires
scientifiques ou technologique l'école
de la République offre de nombreux choix
à nos élèves mais certainement pas celui
de la laïcité l'article 10 de la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme et du
Citoyen proclame que nul ne doit être
inquiété pour ses opinions même
religieuses pourvu que leur
manifestations ne troublent pas la loi
or aujourd'hui l'ordre public semble
compromis par la montée concomitante du
communautarisme et de l'intégrisme qui
n'épargne pas les écoles de notre pays
les exemples récents sont nombreux comme
celui du lycée de Langevin de La
Seyne-sur-Mer 4 élèves ont souhaité
figurer sur la photo de classe en tenue
traditionnelle islamique refusant de se
plier aux consignes de leur professeur
sous prétexte que chaque personne
devrait venir comme elle le souhaite au
lycée non la laïcité conquise dans le
sang et les larmes le rebours du pouvoir
politique que les religions s’octroyées
n’est pas une option oui la laïcité
incarne cette impartialité cette
neutralité de l'État comme cadre qui
permet d'accueillir toutes les personnes
quel que soit leur convictions ne pas
endoctriner ne pas faire de prosélytisme
telle est la loi du 15 mars 2004 porté
par le président Jacques Chirac et
François Baroin une avancée courageuse
qui interdit aux élèves le port de
signes religieux
ostensible dans les établissements
publics ce port
ostentatoire ne veut aucun bien ni à
l'école ni à la République et de
nombreux élèves aujourd'hui tentent de
se prévaloir de leur foi pour se
soustraire aux règles communes quand
comprendrez-vous qu'il s'agit là d'une
arme contre la laïcité monsieur le
ministre l'école et des emparée face aux
vêtements religieux nos professeurs en
première ligne sont contraint à
l'autocensure par peur des intérêts
craintes de stigmatiser le religieux
s'est immiscé dans la vie
professionnelle des enseignants
monsieur le ministre allez vous faire
preuve de transparence quant aux
chiffres sur les nombres cas d'atteinte
à la laïcité dans nos écoles où
allez-vous continuer sur la politique du
pas de vague
la parole est à Monsieur papeney
ministre de l'éducation nationale
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Julien dive la loi de 2004 est très
claire pardon excusez-moi la loi de 2004
est très claire elle interdit le port de
vêtements de signes religieux
ostentatoire dans les enceintes
scolaires cette loi doit être respectée
je serai ferme et intransigeant
là-dessus
la fermeté monsieur le député la fermeté
et la transparence la fermeté ça
signifie faire appliquer la loi grâce
aux équipes de valeurs de la République
il y a des centaines de personnes qui
dans chaque académie Vienne en appui aux
équipes pédagogiques ça signifie
également la formation des enseignants
dans chaque académie il y a des milliers
d'enseignants qui sont formés à la
laïcité et au moyen de faire respecter
la loi de 2004 il y a également un valet
mécum extrêmement bien fait qui a été
supervisé par le Conseil des Sages de la
laïcité et des valeurs de la République
les élèves qui
contreviennent à la loi de 2004
sont sanctionnés et de nombreux élèves
ont été sanctionnés depuis la rentrée
scolaire enfin il y a aussi la
transparence la transparence ça signifie
la publication mensuelle des données je
m'y suis engagé et nous allons publier
jeudi matin les données à propos du mois
de septembre qui indique une hausse
comme je l'ai déjà précisée dans un
média une hausse des signalements pour
port de vêtements ou d'accessoires de
nature religieuse une baisse des
signalements pour d'autres critères nous
sommes très attentifs à cela nous
publierons toutes les données fermeté
transparence voilà la meilleure manière
de faire appliquer la loi
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Dominique Da Silva
pour le groupe Renaissance merci merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion
nous ne considérons pas un abandon de
poste comme un droit à l'assurance
chômage mais pas plus le recours
systématique à des contrats courts comme
des emplois durables assumer nos devoirs
c'est aussi le gage de nos droits comme
celui de la validation des acquis de
l'expérience qui suppose que l'on
reconnaisse plus facilement les
compétences de toute une période de
travail soyons plus exigeants avec nos
dépenses en faveur de l'emploi l'État et
les collectivités se doivent de mieux
orienter de mieux accompagner les
demandeurs d'emploi mais aussi d'agir
lorsque les actions attendues ne sont
pas au rendez-vous c'est tout l'objet du
projet de loi relatif au marché du
travail que nous nous apprêtons à voter
aussi Monsieur le Ministre pourriez-vous
nous indiquer comment le gouvernement
dans la perspective de France travail
compte décliné en droit et devoirs notre
volonté d'atteindre le plein emploi je
vous remercie je vous remercie la parole
est un monsieur Olivier du stop ministre
du Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député de Da Silva vous
l'avez dit dans un instant votre
assemblée se prononcera sur le projet de
loi pourtant première mesure d'urgence
pour atteindre le plein emploi et
faciliter le fonctionnement du marché du
travail avec ce projet de loi vous avez
l'opportunité de rendre le système
d'indemnisation l'assurance chômage plus
réactif avec un principe simple faire en
sorte que lorsque le marché du travail
va mal le système soit plus protecteur
vous l'avez dit à propos de l'activité
partielle nous aurions pu aussi rappeler
le fait que c'est cette majorité qui
pendant la crise du covid a prolonger
les droits des demandeurs d'emploi
arrivés en fin de droit sont 800 000
personnes qui ont été prolongées c'est
la démonstration que nous savons le
faire mais c'est aussi la volonté de
rendre les règles plus incitatives à la
reprise d'emploi lorsque nous
connaissons des tensions de recrutement
comme celle que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui 60% des PME nous disent
rencontrer des difficultés de
recrutement 30% des entreprises
industrielles nous disent être limités
dans leur capacité de développement par
un problème de pénurie de main d'oeuvre
et ça alors même que nous avons encore
un le chômage à 7,4% soit largement
supérieur à la moyenne européenne c'est
tout le sens de ce texte faire en sorte
d'être plus réactif plus incitatif faire
en sorte que le plein emploi soit non
seulement un outil d'émancipation
progrès social de cohésion mais aussi un
outil qui permette de retrouver notre
souveraineté économique le texte a été
enrichi c'est le travail de la majorité
le travail de l'ensemble des bancs de
l'hémicycle sous la coordination du
rapporteur marque Ferracci que je
remercie pour son application sur ce
texte là au-delà de ce texte
nous allons continuer à décliner les
mesures des mesures pour la formation
des demandeurs d'emploi nous avons
engagé un milliard 400 millions d'euros
ça nous a permis de raccompagner 250 000
demandeurs d'emploi de longue durée vers
l'emploi nous allons mobiliser des
moyens pour l'insertion des publics les
plus éloignés ça passe par un
accompagnement plus intensif plus
renforcé des bénéficiaires du RSA à
d'autres minima sociaux l'objectif n'est
pas le travail obligatoire l'objectif
c'est la logique de droit et devoir de
contrepartie d'activité d'insertion et
de formation pour faire en sorte que
notre responsabilité soit au rendez-vous
soit remplie c'est-à-dire sortir un
maximum de bénéficiaires des minima
sociaux de ceci pour permettre de les
accompagner à l'emploi et enfin à la fin
de la semaine je mobiliserai à nouveau
les services de Pôle Emploi pour
accentuer ce plan de réduction des
tensions merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Roger Vico pour
le groupe socialiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur et concerne la réforme de la
police et au sein de la police de la
réforme de la police judiciaire en
commission des lois il y a quelques
semaines monsieur le ministre vous nous
avez indiqué que cette réforme ne
s'appliquerait pas si l'expérimentation
qui est en cours dans plusieurs
départements en ce moment était
négatives inflexion le week-end de
dernier puisque dans les colonnes du
Parisien vous nous indiquer que
désormais il est simplement question
d'amender la réforme après discussion
avec les organisations syndicales or à
ce jour personne ne dispose d'évaluation
complète ou même synthétique de cette
expérimentation elle est pourtant
majeure et quelque part extraordinaire
il est question factuellement de
fusionner la police judiciaire avec
d'autres services comme la police de
l'air et des frontières la sécurité
publique le renseignement territorial au
niveau de chaque département et sous
l'autorité d'un directeur départemental
de la police nationale
cela signifie tout simplement que l'APJ
ne sera plus l'APG que les policiers qui
avaient jusqu'ici pour eux le temps des
enquêtes les moyens des enquêtes les
territoires des enquêtes pourront les
perdre qu'ils pourront être affectés à
l'encadrement des manifestations
publiques comme c'est déjà le cas dans
les départements tests que le grand
banditisme l'évasion fiscale les trafics
internationaux les investigations les
plus complexes pourront être délaissés
au profit de la petite délinquance de
proximité et donc et donc de la
politique du chiffre nous nous
priverions ainsi volontairement d'un pan
entier de l'expertise policière et non
des moindres Clémenceau doit se
retourner dans sa tombe mais au-delà de
l'efficacité des enquêtes au-delà de la
résolution des affaires et même au-delà
des chiffres c'est l'indépendance de la
justice qui est en cause également en
départementalisant la PJ qui nous le
savons tous traite des dossiers les plus
sensibles y compris politiquement vous
rend beaucoup plus perméable les
relations entre acteurs locaux de la
sécurité et pouvoir exécutif monsieur le
ministre laissez le temps aux missions
d'information de faire leur travail
permettez aux policiers de s'exprimer
associer les magistrats merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Caroline Cayeux
ministre délégué des collectivités
territoriales
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Roger Vico vous interrogez le ministre
de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer sur la
réforme de la police nationale
permettez-moi d'y répondre en son nom le
ministre étant retenu au Sénat pour la
présentation de la locmi vous connaissez
l'attachement du ministre pour notre
police nationale attachement que je
partage tout comme l'ensemble du
gouvernement il a écrit à l'ensemble des
personnels de la direction centrale de
la police judiciaire pour les pour les
assurer de son soutien et de son respect
face à leur engagement leur excellence
et leur professionnalisme sans faille il
a tenu à dissiper dans ce courrier les
craintes et les doutes qui se sont
exprimés ces dernières semaines le
ministre a aussi rappelé que l'objectif
de la réforme et de décloisonner
l'ensemble des services de police afin
de mieux travailler ensemble cette
meilleure organisation pour une
meilleure efficacité nous le devons
français il a ensuite précisé que la
filière judiciaire sera renforcée aucun
policier en PJ ne fera autre chose que
ce qui constitue ces missions
aujourd'hui sur son lieu d'affectation
actuelle quand ton moyen dédié au
traitement de la grande criminalité ils
seront augmentés dans le cadre de la
lochmie dans son message le ministre
précise que l'audit est menée par les
inspections du ministère de l'intérieur
mais aussi de l'inspection générale de
la justice qu'aux saisie avec le garde
des sceaux sur la question de la
relation avec l'autorité judiciaire leur
conclusion sont attendues pour
mi-décembre le ministre discutera avec
leurs organisations syndicales
nouvellement élus pour le cas échéant
amender le texte soyez donc sur monsieur
le député de l'engagement et de l'écoute
du ministre de l'Intérieur pour
moderniser notre service public de la
sécurité en travaillant avec les
services concernés pour co-construire
cette réforme indispensable je vous
remercie madame la ministre donc je
voudrais revenir sur l'incident qui
s'est produit tout à l'heure à la suite
de la question au gouvernement que
Monsieur Loubet a posé à monsieur le
ministre de l'Économie des Finances au
nom de du groupe le rassemblement
national j'avais indiqué en conférence
des présidents il y a une semaine de
cela que je souhaitais que la reprise de
la session les comportements dans
l'hémicycle soient respectueux de
l'institution des autres collègues des
membres du gouvernement et de nos
concitoyens monsieur le député en
proférant la phrase aujourd'hui le live
c'est vous on vous adressant au ministre
de l'économie et des finances vous
l'avez insulté cette insulte et prévu à
il est prévu à l'article 70 que celui
qui se rend coupable d'un jour de
provocation de menaces envers le
président de la République indique le
Premier ministre les membres du
gouvernement et les assemblées prévus
par la Constitution peut faire l'objet
de peine disciple disciplinaire donc je
vous indique que je vous inflige un
rappel à l'ordre avec inscription au
procès-verbal
et que monsieur le député et que
évidemment se rappelle à l'ordre avec
l'inscription au procès-verbal ne vous
dispense pas de présenter de vos excuses
au ministre
[Applaudissements]
alors
la parole est à Madame Sandra rigole
pour le groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres je vais
continuer sur la même thématique que mon
collègue socialiste puisque madame la
ministre vous nous dites que ce n'est
pas fonctionnel la PJ aujourd'hui et
j'ai envie de vous répondre tout dépend
de quel point de vue la réforme de l'APG
portée par ce gouvernement elle risque
de privilégier l'arrestation du petit
trafiquant vite remplacé plutôt que le
démantèlement des réseaux ou du vendeur
à la sauvette plutôt que de ceux qui
l'exploitent c'est le choix de la lutte
contre le sentiment d'insécurité et non
contre l'insécurité elle-même c'est
surtout un coup fatal à la lutte contre
la délinquance économique et financière
déjà si mal en point ces mots sont pas
les miens ce sont ceux de magistrats
d'avocats de policiers de citoyens et
c'est historique comme feront pareil se
monte contre cette réforme c'est
historique qu'à Strasbourg ce vendredi
l'APJ était quasi intégralement devant
l'hôtel de police pour dire non
à la suite du mouvement lancé par leurs
collègues marseillais mais ce mouvement
spontané en fait il n'est que la suite
logique de 10 années de réformes contre
le temps long des enquêtes au profit du
temps court des chiffres et surtout des
statistiques sur lesquels il est aisé de
communiquer politiquement il incarne en
fait le recul du devoir républicain et
de l'intérêt général face aux besoins
uniques de certains politiques et c'est
cela que nous dénonçons avec toutes ces
personnes monsieur le ministre qui n'est
pas là derrière cette critique forte du
tout des DPN de cette
départementalisation c'est la reprise en
main par le politique du travail
judiciaire avec les répercussions
dénoncées notamment par le Conseil
national des barreaux qui est ainsi
dénoncé la séparation des pouvoirs est
une base fondamentale de notre
République qui garantit l'État de droit
se renforcement c'est vers le ministre
qu'il se porte qui à l'instar de
plusieurs de ses collègues a déjà été
mis en cause par la justice et par les
affaires monsieur le ministre se dit
très attaché à la police française et
aux revendications de ces agents merci
dès lors pourquoi persister à démanteler
ce métier que ces agents aiment et qui
comptent pour notre démocratie la parole
est à monsieur Éric Dupont Moretti garde
des sceaux ministre de la justice
[Applaudissements]
qu'il est doux qu'il est doux madame la
députée de vous entendre défendre la
police nationale
vous savez que cette réforme est dans
les tuyaux depuis une trentaine d'années
je devrais même dire dans les tuyaux
socialistes puisque c'est Pierre joggs
qui avait souhaité que la réforme soit
faite et c'est Gérald Darmanin qui a le
courage de la faire maintenant
attendez que l'expérimentation se
termine mais expérimentation pas au sens
premier du terme expérimentation au sens
que le Conseil d'État donne de ce mot
c'est-à-dire on va évaluer cette
expérimentation et pour cela il y aura
une inspection constituée de
l'inspection générale de la justice de
l'IGPN en soutien et de l'IGA on peut
pas faire mieux
alors alors concernant les craintes que
vous avez exprimées elles existent il y
a comme toujours d'ailleurs des
contenteurs et des gens qui défendent
aprement cette réforme il y a une
réforme structurelle d'un côté et puis
il y a des craintes qui ont été
exprimées par les magistrats quelles
sont ces craintes j'ai rencontré ce
matin les procureurs généraux c'est
qu'il soit dépossédés de la prérogative
qui est la leur depuis des temps
immémoriaux et qui consiste pour eux à
pouvoir choisir leur enquêteur leur
service d'enquête c'est l'article 12-1
du code de procédure pénale rien ne sera
changé nous sommes corrédacteurs de
cette réforme Gérald Darmanin et
moi-même nous avançons main dans la main
nos services travaillent ensemble ils
échangent nous savons les craintes bien
évidemment et le ministre de l'Intérieur
a tenu hier à rassurer les magistrats
qui pouvaient manifester une certaine
inquiétude en disant que rien de ce
point de vue ne sera changé voilà
j'espère vous avoir rassuré
l'expérimentation n'est pas terminée au
fond vous criez aïe avant un coup que
personne ne veut vous porter voilà c'est
assez singulier
la parole est à Monsieur Frédéric
bocaletti pour le groupe rassemblement
national
madame la Présidente avant de poser ma
question je voudrais simplement rappeler
que jamais nous nous laisserons menacer
ou insulter dans cet assemblée cela par
qui que ce soit
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
il y a quelques jours cet élève du lycée
Langevin à La Seyne-sur-Mer dans ma
circonscription en tant filé des
Camilles pour la photo de classe je
rappelle que ce vêtement traditionnel
est porté pour se rendre à la mosquée
chaque jour l'islamisme radical fait de
l'emprise dans l'école au mépris de la
loi de 2004 c'est coup de boutons
incessant fait sur les murs protecteurs
de la laïcité je remercie ces
enseignants qui tiennent encore bon pour
que l'école de la République garde sa
neutralité religieuse monsieur le
ministre au début du mois vous
conseillez dans le Figaro que le port de
tenue islamique représentait la première
cause de signalement parmi les 627
enregistrés en seulement quatre mois
et la secrétaire d'État la citoyenneté
vous connaissez que le port des abayens
en milieu scolaire était un marqueur
religieux porté en signe de provocation
malheureusement nous constatons que
cette prise de conscience ne se traduit
pas dans les faits à quelques jours du
deuxième assassinat atroce islamiste de
Samuel Paty l'omerta dans l'éducation
nationale règne encore se rajouter
politique le pas de vagues et rigueur
alors Monsieur ministre quand allez-vous
enfin ordonner que toutes les atteintes
à la laïcité dans établissement
scolaires face objet de sanctions
immédiates systématique et sévère je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur papenda
ministre de l'éducation nationale
merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député bocality la loi de
2004 est en effet très clair et je l'ai
mentionné il y a un instant et le
interdit le port de signe religieux
ostensible dans les écoles et les
établissements scolaires et la loi doit
être respectée pour cela nous avons des
équipes valeurs de la République dans
toutes les académies qui viennent en
appui des chefs d'établissement et des
équipes éducatives lorsqu'elles en font
la demande et qui se déplacent également
dans les lycées les collèges et les
écoles dans 20% des cas nous avons
également un vade-mecum qui précise les
conditions de cette loi de 2004 et nous
appliquons très fermement la loi en ce
qui concerne les vêtements de nature
religieuse auxquelles vous faites
allusion pour cela le va des mécum
précise que les élèves concernés sont
admonestés les familles sont reçus on
leur demande de retirer les vêtements et
s'il refuse ils sont sanctionnés et des
sanctions ont été prononcées par
ailleurs nous avons également décidé de
publier mensuellement les données
relatives au signalement pour le mois de
septembre ces données indiquent une
hausse des signalements pour port de
vêtements ou de signes religieux ils
indiquent par ailleurs une baisse des
signalements pour entrave à l'exercice
pédagogique ou pour refus de participer
à des activités pédagogiques
je répète fermeté et transparence et
applications intransigeantes de la loi
de 2004 je vous remercie monsieur le
mesnistre la parole est à Monsieur ah
excusez-moi allez-y je ministre
excusez-moi mais il aura fallu 12 jours
pour que les sanctions tombent au lycée
Langevin et tout simplement parce que
j'avais rendu public à faire mais tout
ça ne m'étonne pas monsieur ministre
parce que vous êtes vous-même un
communautariste nous nous avons des
solutions en février 2021 Marine Le Pen
déposait un projet de loi visant à
combattre l'islamisme il n'a jamais été
voté
inscrivez-le à l'ordre du jour
inscrivez-le à l'ordre du jour de la
prochaine session et nous commencerons
peut-être à croire en votre volonté de
lutter contre l'entrisme islamiste je
vous remercie alors c'est quand même
incroyable vous commencez votre propos
vous pouvez quitter les missiles non
vous commencez votre propos en disant
que vous ne tenerez aucune injure dans
l'hémicycle et vous recommencez c'est
quand même incroyable est-ce qu'on peut
pas se respecter ici
[Applaudissements]
moi je peux prononcer des rappels alors
à volonté tant que ça justifie mon cher
collègue donc je prononce un rappel à
l'ordre à votre égard également
[Musique]
et je demande vraiment à ce que chacun
se respecte dans cette hémicycle c'est
ça la démocratie
merci beaucoup mes chers collègues donc
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Blanchet pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre chargé la
transition numérique Jean-Noël barreau
tout d'abord au nom du groupe démocrate
permettez-moi de vous féliciter pour
votre brillant très élection ce weekend
dans la deuxième circonscription des
Yvelines
monsieur le ministre notre pays a subi
une augmentation de 65% des attaques
cybercriminelles avec 173000 dossiers
ouverts en 2021 nous assaillants s'en
prenaient d’abord aux grandes
entreprises qui depuis se protègent
mieux puis se sont mis à attaquer nos
PME puis maintenant nos collectivités à
chaque fois le même procédé on vole les
fichiers des clients des patients la
comptabilité et on réclame une rançon
pour peut-être se voir restituer son
bien tout cela entraînant l'interruption
du business la détérioration du matériel
informatique la fuite de données et
l'impact sur la notoriété pour les
entreprises les sommes dérobées avoisine
à minimale et 5000 euros et peuvent
atteindre plus de 100.000 euros c'est
ainsi une perte de 27% de chiffre
d'affaires l'an passé pour nos
entreprises mais combien pour les
collectivités et pour les hôpitaux comme
Dax Corbeil-Essonnes Paris et Rouen il y
a deux semaines ce fut le tour de la
mairie de Caen avec l'arrêt de nombreux
services dont l'accès aux offres
d'emploi public et ses fichiers hier
c'est le Département de Seine-Maritime
qui a été ATT là encore de nombreux
services et leurs fichiers sont touchés
dans l'ensemble des démarches concernant
les allocations pour l'autonomie et le
handicap totalement indisponible nous
avons des pays suspects sur la
provenance des attaques et à l'heure de
la guerre en Ukraine nous savons que le
cyber fait partie des armes modernes de
déstabilisation avec des organisations
criminelles qui s'organisent en
industrie de la cyber aussi comment
peut-on mieux protéger notre tissu
économique nos hôpitaux et nos
collectivités face à ces attaques
massives qui deviennent de plus en plus
récurrentes et qui constituent un butin
conséquent et précieux pour ces réseaux
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Noël Barrault ministre
délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Christophe Blanchet d'abord soyez
remercier pour vos félicitations ce
résultat sonne comme un encouragement à
poursuivre le travail engagé sur
l'autorité du Président de la République
de la première ministre dans le dialogue
dans le compromis dans le respect de
l'institution des institutions cela va
sans dire mais semble-t-il ça va mieux
en le disant et toujours au service de
l'intérêt général vous m'interrogez
monsieur le député au sujet de l'attaque
brutal qui a frappé le Département de
Seine-Maritime dimanche dernier j'ai pu
m'entretenir avec le président Bélanger
et je veux saluer la réponse exemplaire
qui a été apportée par les équipes du
département qui ont sollicité les
autorités compétentes dans les minutes
qui ont suivi le début de l'attaque
comme 700 collectivités le Département
de Seine-Maritime était entrée dans un
parcours de sécurisation dispensé par
l'ansy dans le cadre du plan de relance
qui a certainement contribué à limiter
les conséquences dramatique de cette
attaque mais comme vous le rappelez ce
qui s'est passé à l'hôpital de Dax à
l'hôpital de Corbeil-Essonnes à la
mairie de Caen et dimanche dernier au
Département de Seine-Maritime nous
rappelle que la cybercriminalité est une
grande menace de notre temps que la
criminalité la délinquance migre dans
l'espace numérique de que nous devons
tout mettre en œuvre et redoubler nos
efforts pour apporter une réponse à
cette menace
prévention répression remédiation c'est
ainsi que nous voulons avec Bruno Le
Maire répondre à cette nouvelle menace
avec Lanci qui fait un travail
remarquable d'accompagnement et de
remédiation et que la première ministre
a décidé de renforcer dans ses effectifs
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
finance 2023 avec cyber
maveillance.gouv.fr qui accompagne des
dizaines de milliers de victimes
collectivités entreprises particuliers
chaque jour dites-le autour de vous
mesdames et messieurs les députés en cas
de doute cyber malveillance.gouv.fr avec
la locmic qui est présentée aujourd'hui
par le ministre de l'Intérieur qui sera
examiné prochainement par votre
assemblée bref vous l'avez entendu nous
sommes pleinement mobilisés pour
apporter une réponse à cette menace
en l'absence du ministre de l'Intérieur
madame la Première ministre
c'est l'ébullition j'ai bien dit
l'ébullition aujourd'hui au sein de la
police judiciaire la PJ des
manifestations historiques partout dans
le pays c'est du jamais vu depuis la
création des Brigades du Tigre à cela à
cela quel est votre réponse votre
réponse a été ni plus ni moins que le
limoge j'ai bien dit le limogeage du
Directeur de la PJ de Marseille
ericarella pourtant le retour des
expérimentations est d'ores et déjà
négatif pourtant les alertes remontent
de toutes parts et c'est l'ensemble du
monde judiciaire qui est vent debout
contre cette réforme jusqu'au procureur
général près la Cour de cassation
François molens François Molins pleuré
avant d'être battu non monsieur
Dupont-Moretti non non je ne le crois
pas car oui cette réforme met a mal la
séparation des pouvoirs en plaçant les
enquêteurs de l'APJ sous la hiérarchie
directe des préfets qui sont le même
sous votre régime vous vous les membres
du gouvernement bah c'est bien à ça que
servent les préfets me semble-t-il non
aujourd'hui le problème de la police
n'est pas la justice quoi qu'en pensent
et quoi qu'en disent vos amis factions
mal par cette réforme le principe le
principe de sûreté qui est dans
l'article 6 de la Déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen dans un état de
droit dans un état de droit quoi qu'il
en soit les enquêteurs sont sous la
seule égide autorité des magistrats et
non pas les desiderata les lubies de
tels ou telle ministre de l'Intérieur
obsédé par ces chiffres contrairement à
ce que vous soutenez la PJ ne peut être
diluée dans les autres services elle a
ses spécificités elle a ses exigences
procédurales et c'est ça qui crée
l'efficacité c'est ça qui permet de
lutter contre la délinquance économique
et financière la criminalité organisée
toujours est-il que je voudrais savoir
si vous conf mais comme ça a été écrit
dans le courrier du 9 octobre coucou ma
chère collègues la réponse va vous être
apportée par le ministre de la Justice
Eric Dupont-Moretti
[Applaudissements]
à vrai dire
vous êtes au paradoxe ce que Richter est
au séisme une référence
[Applaudissements]
votre votre
votre votre mentor votre mentor à
secouer des officiers de police
judiciaire physiquement s'entend et un
magistrat du parquet vous dites
régulièrement que la police tue et voilà
qu'aujourd'hui vous vous levez pour
soi-disant défendre la police c'est
extraordinaire alors
il y a un point sur lequel madame vous
avez raison le problème de la police
n'est pas la justice le problème de la
police c'est la délinquance là-dessus je
vous suis pour le reste j'ai déjà
répondu j'ai dit qu'il y avait une
expérimentation j'ai dit que ce texte
serait que signé j'ai dit que les
magistrats avaient exprimé un certain
nombre de doutes et ils ont légitimement
le droit de l'exprimer nous avons vu ce
matin une réunion je regrette que vous
n'ayez pas participé avec les procureurs
généraux voilà les choses sont très
claires écoutez ma réponse sinon ça sert
à rien de me poser la question l'article
12-1 du code de procédure pénale ne sera
pas modifié les prérogatives légitimes
que les magistrats ont quant au choix de
l'enquêteur au choix du service tout
cela ne sera pas changé alors pour le
reste j'ai un peu de mal à répondre à
votre question madame la députée car
pour vous dire les choses je ne l'ai pas
comprise la question
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Steve Chaillou
pour le groupe GDR
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
madame la Première ministre Johan dans
cette législature avec chacun leur
sensibilité voici ce que mes collègues
des territoires hors de l'Hexagone vous
martelleront chacun de manière
différente et selon nos sensibilités
propres ce n'est pas seulement la
distance vis-à-vis de Paris 10 15 20 000
km qui fonde les spécificités dans nos
territoires ce sont nos si nos cultures
nos histoires nos langues et nos
réalités sur cela se font des
dispositifs exorbitants du droit
métropolitain pour pouvoir notamment
privilégier l'affectation sur le
territoire d'origine via les centres
d'intérim matériel et moraux CIM or nos
syndicats nous-mêmes nous étonnons des
récentes évolutions qui tendent à
réduire la transparence des décisions
prises au sein des commissions chargées
de l'affectation des fonctionnaires deux
conséquences directes et permanents dans
nos territoires des soupçons et des
contestations qui germent dans le
terreau d'un sentiment d'une profonde
injustice la main de norme soumis à
l'appréciation de chaque administration
avec des cette pliolitaire des statues
particuliers des lignes directrices
propres nourries une incompréhension en
témoigne les défaillances persistance
qui impactent les néotitulaires et les
lauréastagiaires originaires de nos
territoires au sein de la fonction
publique et qui nous valent chaque jour
de recevoir des demandes d'intervention
en faveur de nos administrés ces
derniers reçoivent d'abord des refus
d'affectation confirmés après
contestation soit disant pour absence de
poste alors que nous voyons sur place
des postes vacants et des besoins
clients ces ambiguïtés imposent que nous
portions à la connaissance de chaque
ministère les cas dont nous sommes
saisis pour ces raisons je vous le dis
si ce que nous exprimions dans notre
lettre de juillet dernier à l'intention
du ministère de l'Éducation nationale et
il est itérant notre intention ferme et
collective de ne plus vouloir seulement
répondre à des intentions individuelles
mais bien d'instaurer un cadre
législatif construit en concertation
avec l'ensemble des territoires
concernés madame la Première ministre
votre gouvernement est-il disposé à
prendre des mesures afin d'harmoniser
les conditions association du CIM et a
renforcer la place du CMM dans les
critères d'affectation marulu merci
beaucoup monsieur le député la parole
est à Monsieur Stanislas Guérini
ministre de la transformation et de la
fonction publique merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le députés Steve
Chaillot m'interroger sur la question
des droits des fonctionnaires en
Polynésie et c'est un sujet sur lequel
nous travaillons ensemble avec le
ministre de l'Intérieur et les outre-mer
Gérald Darmanin ainsi que le ministre
délégué chargé des Outre-mer
Jean-François caraco j'aurais profité de
ma réponse pour saluer le travail des
fonctionnaires de la fonction publique
d'État la fonction publique hospitalière
des fonctions publiques territoriales en
Polynésie ils font un travail
remarquable en Polynésie et surtout nos
territoires ultramarins ils font vivre
partout notre pacte républicain vous
interroger plus spécifiquement sur les
centres d'intérêts matériel
vous le savez c'est à travers un travail
de l'Assemblée nationale et cette
majorité qui a décidé en 2020 de
permettre aux agents originaires de
Polynésie de bénéficier comme tous les
agents
ultramarins de congés bonifiés qui
découlent de ces fameux ci-mm c'était
une exception injuste il faut le dire
monsieur le député et depuis 2020 ce
sujet est clarifié je le redis devant la
représentation nationale ce congé est
essentiel pour accompagner
l'installation des fonctionnaires
polynésiens hors de leur territoire mais
je veux le dire aussi avec clarté devant
vous il faut veiller à ce que des
préoccupations que je pourrais qualifier
ici parfois de tatillonne de certaines
administrations ne viennent pas remettre
en cause ce principe pour les agents
polynésiens c'est l'engagement en tant
que ministre de la transformation et de
la fonction publique que je prends ici
devant vous j'ajoute monsieur le député
que c'est aussi pour régler une
inégalité de traitement que le ministère
des armées a étendu en avril 2022 le
bénéfice de l'indemnité d'installation
dans l'Hexagone au militaire polynésien
vous le voyez nous agissons et nous nous
engageons
et madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale monsieur le
ministre nous commémorons dimanche 16
octobre prochain
l'assassinat barbare de Samuel Paty
professeur d'histoire-géographie
décapité par un terroriste islamiste
parce qu'il avait choisi d'enseigner la
liberté et l'esprit critique je serai à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine ce dimanche
pour commémorer sa mémoire ce dimanche
il ne devrait être question que de cet
hommage notre majorité a voté la loi
confortant les principes de la
République qui a enfin permis à notre
état d'avoir en main des outils
efficaces pour lutter contre toutes les
formes de séparatisme sur notre
territoire nous savons qu'une
mobilisation islamiste sur les réseaux
sociaux à destination des jeunes
existent des centaines de messages
provenant de contes anonymes appelle les
enfreindre ou contourner les règles de
la laïcité à banaliser le port du voile
des abayas ou des hijab a porté
ostensiblement des signes religieux à
l'école en sortie scolaire à pratiquer
la prière pendant les récréations et à
conflictualisé davantage leur rapport
avec les enseignants
sous couvert d'une désobéissance civile
ses campagnes offensives sur les réseaux
sociaux sont nombreuses fréquentes et
préoccupantes les enseignants souhaitent
de l'accompagnement et de la formation
pour faire respecter les lois de la
République et enseigner librement tous
les sujets sans autocensure la ligne de
la majorité claire chaque élève chacun
de nos enfants doit pouvoir bénéficier
de l'universalisme républicain comment
agissez-vous monsieur le ministre pour
réaffirmer dans tous les établissements
scolaires nos principes républicains
fondateurs merci je vous remercie la
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la Caroline
Caroline Adam vous l'avez rappelé nous
nous apprêtons à rendre hommage à Samuel
Paty à l'occasion du deuxième
anniversaire de son ignoble assassinat
par un terroriste islamiste et j'ai une
pensée émue pour lui mon collègue
professeur d'histoire
à cette
occasion
à cette occasion je remettrai ce samedi
à la Sorbonne en présence de sa famille
le prix Samuel Paty a des classes
engagées dans des actions sur la
citoyenneté et la laïcité votre question
est l'occasion pour moi madame la
députée de réaffirmer un principe simple
la laïcité n'est pas négociable c'est la
mise en œuvre c'est la condition de la
mise en oeuvre des valeurs de la
République c'est la condition
sinequanone de la protection de l'école
de toute influence et de tout pro alors
c'est vrai nous avons affaire depuis
quelques mois à des agitateurs
professionnels sur les réseaux sociaux
qui excitent qui incite à enfreindre la
loi qui touille une bien mauvaise soupe
en ne visant ni l'intérêt des élèves que
je mets en garde à ce sujet
ni celui de l'école ni celui de la
République avec le ministère de
l'Intérieur nous répliquons et
répliquerons d'une manière appropriée je
vous le dis mesdames et messieurs les
députés
la République est plus forte que Tik Tok
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Annie cousin pour le
contrat semblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Béchu ministre de
la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires monsieur le
ministre nous vivons un immense scandale
vous avez dû entendre le témoignage du
maire de Neuilly-sur-Marne qui dénonce
le raquette organisé par certains grands
groupes pour faire exploser la facture
énergétique des collectivités le prix du
mégawatt-heure d'électricité et parfois
multipliée par 30 le prix du mégawatt de
heure de gaz lui multiplié par 16
malheureusement le gouvernement laisse
faire dans ma circonscription du
Lot-et-Garonne les mers sont très
inquiets quelques exemples à
tournon-D'agenais la facture énergétique
va passer de 15000 à 60 000 euros à
peine d'agener de 60000 à 320 000 euros
et à Villeneuve-sur-Lot mer m'indique un
surcoût de plus de 800.000 euros c'est
totalement inacceptable de plus si les
mers refusent de signer ou tout
simplement ne peuvent pas donc ces
nouvelles conditions tarifaires
exorbitantes
payer leurs factures les opérateurs
menacent de couper l'électricité aux
communes c'est du raquette organisé
monsieur le ministre la situation est
grave les maires sont inquiets que
comptez-vous faire pour accompagner de
toute urgence toutes les communes de
France pour éviter qu'elles aussi se
retrouvent sans électricité cet hiver je
vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires madame la présidente
madame la députée Annick cousin vous
vous faites les coûts d'une situation
que nous connaissons et à laquelle nous
travaillons d'arrache-pied déjà depuis
un certain nombre de semaines j'aimerais
d'abord rappeler ici que 28 000 des
35000 communes de son pays sont protégés
par le bouclier tarifaire puisque toutes
les communes de moins de 10 salariés il
y en a certainement dans votre
circonscription et de moins de 2
millions de budgets bénéficient du tarif
réglementé vous évoquez un certain
nombre de cas parmi celles-là la commune
de Neuilly-sur-Marne dont le maire est
reçu aujourd'hui au ministère de la
cohésion des territoires et vous évoquez
surtout la situation dans laquelle un
certain nombre de ces élus se retrouve à
recevoir des factures qui contenu de la
concurrence qui s'applique sur les
communes au-delà de cette taille peuvent
se retrouver avec des qui sont énormes
le premier sujet c'est d'obtenir la
baisse des prix de l'électricité puisque
des rendent se constituent avec une
décoration entre les prix de production
et les prix de revente et c'est la
première ligne sur laquelle nous nous
battons à l'échelle européenne le
président de la République le ministre
de l'Économie la première ministre pour
faire en sorte d'arriver à diminuer ses
tarifs deuxièmement c'est la
contribution de la rendre sur laquelle
nous espérons évidemment que vous
viendrez au secours de la majorité des
amendements qui ont été déposés pour
faire en sorte de permettre que ces
mécanismes qui nous permettent de
récupérer de l'argent puisse ensuite
accompagner les filets de sécurité qui
ont d'ores et déjà été voté au titre de
l'année 2022 430 millions dont les
décrets ont été présentés il y a
quelques jours devant le Comité des
finances locales et nous venons avec
Gabriel Attal de préciser les conditions
dans lesquelles les préfets pourront
débloquer des acomptes pour couvrir une
partie des Delta des prix de l'énergie
la deuxième étape c'est ce qui arrive
pour la première fois depuis 13 ans le
gouvernement propose une augmentation du
niveau de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement les 210 millions qui
avaient été présentés sont devenus 320
millions d'euros après le congrès
d'intercommunalité de France ou la
première ministre a fait ses annonces
nous avons près de 2 milliards d'euros
dans le cadre du fond vert qui seront
disponibles l'année prochaine pour le
soutien l'investissement parce que le
sujet c'est aussi la rénovation et enfin
le nouveau dispositif présenté par le
rapport par le rapporteur général
Cazeneuve pour mieux accompagner les
collectivités
monsieur le ministre ne faites pas comme
si vous n'aviez pas été mère vous
sous-estimez les problématiques agissez
et agissez maintenant c'est pas l'année
prochaine
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur
je croyais que vous aviez terminé
excusez-moi ma chère
je croyais que vous vouliez terminer
votre intervention parce que vous aviez
encore 15 secondes mais tout va bien
donc la parole est à Monsieur William
Martinet pour le groupe la France
insoumise
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre du
Logement Olivier Klein je vais parler de
la misère celle qui submerge notre pays
et dont l'une des expressions les plus
insoutenables et le sans-abrisme des
enfants chaque soir ce sont 2000 enfants
sans abri qui sont signalés au 115 sans
qu'aucune solution d'émergement
d'urgence ne leur soit proposée ces
enfants passeront la nuit dehors je pèse
mes mots mais je demande à la
représentation nationale de prendre la
mesure du caractère inédit et grave de
la situation aujourd'hui en France sur
le territoire de la République des
enfants de parfois deux ou trois ans
dorment même le trottoir de nos villes
voilà la réalité monsieur le ministre je
sais que cette situation est pour vous
inacceptable ce sont d'ailleurs les mots
que vous avez utilisés il y a deux
semaines lors d'un déplacement à Lyon
vous avez été interpellé par le
Collectif Citoyen jamais sans toi donc
je tiens ici à saluer l'action le
collectif vous a alerté concernant la
situation de plus de 100 enfants sans
abri dans la métropole lyonnaise vous
leur avez répondu
direct à la télévision et vous vous êtes
engagé à mettre à l'abri ses enfants
dans les 48 heures monsieur le ministre
j'ai donc plusieurs questions très
précises à vous poser la première nous
sommes plus de 48 heures après votre
déclaration ou en est la mise à l'abri
de ses enfants deuxième question les
enfants sans abri de Paris de Bordeaux
de Rennes ou d'ailleurs doivent-ils
attendre que le ministre se déplace dans
leur ville doivent-ils attendre que la
détresse soit médiatisée pour que vous
leur proposiez une mise à l'abri et
troisième et dernière question monsieur
le ministre vous défendez un projet de
loi de finances qui prévoit la
suppression de 7000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence vu la saturation du 115 nous
savons que la suppression de ces places
va mécaniquement augmenter le nombre de
personnes sans abri monsieur le ministre
on ne peut déplorer les effets dont on
chéri les causes on ne peut déplorer le
sans-abrisme des enfants et réaliser des
économies budgétaires en supprimant des
places d'hébergement d'urgence monsieur
le ministre allez vous renoncer à ces
économies indignes je vous remercie je
vous remercie la parole à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre monsieur le
député William Martinet Olivier Klein
n'étant pas là cet après-midi je veux
d'abord vous assurer qu'au-delà des
situations que vous dépanner
ces situations et la question plus large
de l'hébergement du toit pour chacun ici
dans ce pays et bien une priorité du
gouvernement et du ministère de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires le budget qui vous est
présenté dans quelques jours
consacre plus de 2 milliards d'euros et
une augmentation de 113 millions d'euros
pour la création de place entre la
situation que vous décrivez et les
chiffres que je donne il faut comprendre
que la volonté qui est la nôtre c'est de
diminuer les logements hôteliers dont
nous savons à la fois les limites pour
augmenter dans le cadre du Plan logement
d'abord des places qui soient durables
et qui soient plus dignes ce qui vous
est proposé ces 5900 créations de place
en cas d'art en CAES en CPH et en
outre-mer en UDA c'est 1000 places de
plus pour les femmes victimes de
violence et leurs enfants nous allons
atteindre à la fin de cette année le
chiffre de 10000 places et ce chiffre
nous allons encore ajouter 1000 places
supplémentaires au titre de l'année 2023
c'était un engagement du gouvernement il
est tenu les niveaux d'hébergement qui
ont atteint ces derniers qui ont été
atteints ces derniers mois en
particulier dans la continuité de la
crise sanitaire sont historique notre
pays est celui qui concentre le plus de
place de logement d'urgence à l'échelle
de toute l'Europe rapporté à sa
population
ce matin Olivier Klein ce matin Olivier
Klein a reçu l'ensemble des associations
d'hébergement d'urgence avec la dial un
observatoire hebdomadaire des situations
préoccupantes et mis en place cette
observatoire pilotée par la dial toutes
les semaines fera un point sur les
situations préoccupantes et concernant
les familles concrètes des solutions
déjà été trouvées pour les familles sur
lesquelles Olivier Klein était
interpellé je vous remercie je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Servane Hugues
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci Madame merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre délégué chargé des personnes
handicapées en France plus de 60% des
personnes en perte d'autonomie sont
aidés par un ou plusieurs de leurs
proches ces aidants ou aidantes
représentent ont 11 millions de
personnes et seront près de 20 millions
en 2060 le rôle de l'aidant dans notre
société n'est plus à démontrer il est un
véritable soutien pour la personne aidé
que ce soit un membre de sa famille un
conjoint un enfant un parent un ami une
personne avec laquelle il nous une
relation de confiance tout à fait
singulière il lui procure un soutien
psychologique physique un aquarium
accompagnement de tout instant une
protection et des appuis afin d'assurer
également le maintien le maintien de sa
vie sociale nous ne pouvons que saluer
les nombreux avancées portées ces
derniers mois par notre majorité la
location journalière projetant qui a été
revalorisée au niveau du SMIC le congé
procédant qui a été élargi à davantage
de bénéficiaires et enfin dernièrement
la VAE ouverte aux aidants dans le cadre
du projet de loi portant mesures
d'urgence relative au fonctionnement du
marché du travail enfin la stratégie
agit pour les aidants de 2019 pour la
période 2020-2022 à œuvré dans le but de
leur permettre de concilier vie
professionnelle et vie personnelle c'est
aussi une avancée pour la reconnaissance
de leur rôle indispensable et pour la
valorisation de leur statut la prochaine
stratégie qui débutera en 2023 sera
l'occasion d'aller plus loin encore et
de renforcer ses efforts dans le but de
faciliter le quotidien des proches
aidants madame la ministre dans cette
optique comment comptez-vous favoriser
les possibilités de répit que l'on sait
indispensable pour lutter contre les cas
d'épuisement dans ces familles quels
sont les perspectives pour mieux prendre
en compte les besoins des aidants de
personnes en situation de handicap ou de
personnes malades je vous remercie je
vous remercie la parole est à Geneviève
Darius sec ministre délégué chargé des
personnes handicapées
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés et Madame la
Députée Servane Hugues d'abord je vous
remercie sincèrement de mettre en
lumière les aidants dont le rôle est
précieux dans l'autre société le 6
octobre dernier était la journée des
aidants et nous tenions ce jour-là avec
la première ministre le premier comité
interministériel du handicap de ce
gouvernement nous avons pu y entendre la
parole des aidants leur place est
évidemment essentielle mais souvent trop
méconnu ils sont encore nombreux à
ignorer le rôle qu'ils en dossent et les
droits qu'il accompagne un tiers d'entre
eux délaisse leur propre santé
incarnent pas à se ménager de répit
alors oui le gouvernement est mobilisé
pour améliorer leur quotidien alors oui
beaucoup de progrès ont été réalisés
comme vous venez de le dire par la
stratégie nationale pour les aidants qui
vient de se déployer et oui il ne faut
action accentuer nos efforts
élaborons avec le ministère des
solidarités Jean-Christophe combe et le
ministère de la Santé François Brown une
nouvelle stratégie baptisée agir avec
les aidants elle sera co-construite
comme toutes les stratégies que nous
mettons à neuves avec les premiers
concernés et donc de personnes en
situation de handicap de personnes âgées
mais aussi et aussi j'allais dire deux
personnes malades l'évolution de la
définition de procédant dans le code de
l'action sociale et des familles
permettra de prendre en compte
l'ensemble de ces situations des danses
la question du répit est majeure et elle
sera au coeur de cette stratégie je
tiens à rappeler l'engagement du
président de la République
soit de garantir deux semaines de répit
par an pour les aidants c'est un
engagement fort aujourd'hui 252
plateformes de répit ont été déployés il
nous faudra renforcer ces solutions de
répit en termes de maillage territorial
il faut qu'elle soit présente partout
sur le territoire de notre pays ainsi
que en termes de diversité de l'offre
merci Madame la Ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Benjamin sainte huile pour le
groupe Viot
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre le Maire Monsieur
le Ministre sur ses bancs il y a
quelques minutes le député petit a
évoqué la situation industrielle
française dans le Pas-de-Calais je veux
y revenir un instant pour vous permettre
d'être peut-être plus précis sur
l'accompagnement du gouvernement
j'appartiens à un Territoire du Nord qui
est marqué par l'histoire industrielle
qui a beaucoup souffert des différentes
crises et qui a vu fermer les portes de
bon nombre d'entreprises et de groupes
qui avaient pourtant porté le fleuron de
la nation industrie France je pense chez
moi à hackers à Noves à Sambre-et-Meuse
ou encore à Phoenix il y a quelques
jours la verrerie de Boussois AGC a
annoncé qu'au regard de l'explosion des
coûts de l'énergie multiplié par 3 les
135 salariés verrez leur avenir
questionner et sans doute la moitié
d'entre eux voire deux tiers serait
directement impacté par les décisions
qui sont devant nous monsieur le
ministre vous avez évoquer la capacité
du gouvernement à accompagner les
entreprises et je veux le dire par le
passé vous êtes venu sur notre
territoire c'était un Renault Maubeuge
MCA et vous avez permis de faire en
sorte que le Président de la République
tienne les engagements qui avaient été
pris à travers la constitution de
Renault électricité aujourd'hui ce
territoire qui a signé avec le
gouvernement impact qui permet le
rattrapage des difficultés que nous
connaissons est aujourd'hui en grande
souffrance et en grande inquiétude
comment pouvez nous nous rassurer et
rassurer les salariés qui vivent ces
dernières semaines dans l'angoisse de
voir leur emploi disparaître je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie et des finances
[Musique]
je veux redire à quel point je partage
les inquiétudes de Maubeuge de votre
département et de toutes les PME
industrielles de France elle voit
exploser les coups de l'énergie
certaines ont du mal à faire face à ces
factures nous ne laisserons tomber
aucune PME aucune industrie aucun
secteur industriel avec Roland Lescure
la réponse elle est très simple tout
entreprise industrielle qui aurait
aujourd'hui du mal à payer ses factures
et qui aurait une part importante
d'énergie dans son chiffre d'affaires 3%
n'ont pas en 2021 mais fin 2022 pour
tenir compte de l'augmentation des coûts
d'énergie sur 2022 doit s'inscrire sur
le site la direction générale des
finances publiques je ne veux pas être
plus précis pour demander des aides dans
le montant passera de 2 à 4 millions
d'euros et nous proposons de réserver ce
fond de soutien uniquement au PME
c’est-à-dire les entreprises qui ont
moins de 250 salariés celles qui sont
les plus petites les plus fragiles les
plus menacées nous ne laisserons pas
tomber notre industrie face à la flambée
des prix du gaz et face à la flambée des
prix de l'électricité et nous voulons
dans le même temps et c'est l'objectif
de cette majorité
accélérer la reconquête industrielle
baissez les impôts de production
accélérer sur le véhicule électrique le
président de la République aura
l'occasion de faire des annonces lundi
prochain au moment de l'ouverture du
Salon de l'automobile il y a une
transition elle est difficile elle est
rendue encore plus difficile pour passer
du véhicule thermique au véhicules
électriques par l'explosion des coûts de
l'énergie mais nous ferons face en
shootant les entreprises et en ayant une
politique claire de souveraineté
industrielle je vous remercie monsieur
sainte-huile
oui monsieur le ministre simplement dire
que à ce stade les dispositifs que vous
avez bien voulu mettre en place depuis
l'été on montrait leurs limites et que
malheureusement nous sommes face à la
situation du moment et du coup je forme
le vœu qu'avec votre collègue Lescure et
peut-être en associant le collègue du
soft on soit en capacité d'accompagner
l'entreprise qui vont mettre en place
des situations de chômage partiel
allongée pour garder les compétences
dans nos industries et permettre demain
le renouveau l'industrie française je
vous remercie je vous remercie la
dernière question sera posée par Madame
Alexandra Martin pour le groupe les
républicains
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
santé et de la prévention l'accès à la
santé est un droit pour tous majeur vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure la force
de notre système de santé et de pouvoir
répondre à cet engagement je souhaite
faire écho aujourd'hui au cri d'alarme
des pharmaciens et des patients sur les
ruptures d'approvisionnement en
médicaments qui se multiplient et qui
sont une des sources de dégradation de
notre système de santé sur le site
internet de l'Agence nationale de
sécurité des médicaments la liste de ces
produits s'allonge dangereusement les
ruptures d'approvisionnement des
pharmacies durant au moins une semaine
ont quasiment doublé depuis le début de
l'année passant de 6,5% à 12,5% du
nombre de références monsieur le
ministre nous sommes en crise sanitaire
os de la demande mondiale crise
énergétique bien sûr guerre en Ukraine
mais le vrai problème et la
désindustrialisation tout comme la
fixation par la France
compris trop bas qui ne permet plus aux
industriels de fournir des médicaments
courants de façon régulière le résultat
des milliers de malades qui ne peuvent
plus se soigner ces situations de
pénurie ou de tension concernent des
centaines de références dont des
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutiques
majeurs comme des chimiothérapies ou
encore des médicaments pour le diabète
de type 2 et peuvent entraîner
l'interruption ou le report du
traitement d'intérêt vital et ça c'est
inacceptable alors Monsieur le Ministre
ma question est la suivante comment en
sommes-nous arrivés là comment la mise
en place en 2021 d'un stock national de
4 mois n'a-t-elle rien fait pour
empêcher la dégradation continue de la
situation merci
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur François Braun ministre de la
Santé de la prévention
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Alexandra Martin le médicament est un
enjeu stratégique majeur pour notre pays
que ce soit dans son accès pour nos
concitoyens dans les problèmes de
pénurie que vous évoquez tout en faisant
la différence entre la pénurie sur le
médicament et la pénurie sur les
molécules qui est un peu différent
également dans le soutien de
l'innovation en termes de médicaments et
dans l'attractivité de notre pays pour
cette industrie c'est également un enjeu
de souveraineté nationale majeur comme
nous avons pu tous le constater dans le
cadre de l'épidémie covid le
gouvernement a fait et continue à faire
beaucoup par exemple pour l'innovation
avec 10 milliards d'euros sur la table
un accès raccourci simplifié pour les
médicaments innovants pour que justement
nos concitoyens est un accès plus rapide
aux médicaments qui ont un effet réel
effet sur leur sur leur pathologie en
2023 la sécurité sociale va investir
près de 800 millions d'euros de plus
l'industrie du médicament de plus parce
que nous respectons les engagements que
le Président de la République a pris
face à l'industrie du médicament nous
allons même au-delà des engagements qui
sont des engagements de dépenses et vous
le savez comme moi que ce sont des
dépenses de sécurité sociale
les efforts du gouvernement ne sont
pourtant pas incompatibles avec des
efforts juste et proportionnés que nous
demandons à l'industrie du secteur à
l'industrie du médicament c'est un
secteur qui est en forte croissance et
ces demandes cet effort que nous lui
demandons va de perdre bien entendu avec
l'engagement du gouvernement de
maintenir le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens et de ne pas augmenter
l'impôt ni de diminuer leurs droits face
à la maladie
pour autant nous avons entendu les
professionnels du secteur nous
travaillons avec eux à une rénovation de
la régulation structurelle de ce secteur
et à la façon de passer au mieux le cap
de cette année 2023 la maîtrise des
dépenses de santé madame la député c'est
un enjeu majeur d'équilibre de notre
système de protection sociale mais vous
le savez je
vous remercie oui merci Monsieur le
Ministre simplement rappelé que la crise
aujourd'hui elle est aujourd'hui et
c'est en ce moment qu'il faut la régler
et c'est maintenant qu'il faut agir
merci bon merci la séance des questions
gouvernement est terminée la séance et
suspendus pour une durée de 10 minutes